What's up y'all? Thank you for being
here. An especially warm welcome if you
are new as always, Adventist or
otherwise.
Last week, we dove into a talk by
celebrity SDA pastor Doug Bachelor that
is titled, "Is Sunday sacred?"
It served as a good example of some of
the common claims that the SDA church
makes against first day sabotarians like
myself, demonstrating that they do not
know what they criticize
in a number of areas, but especially
this area. If you uh if you recall, our
friend Doug has yet to even mention the
new creation a single time. We're about
34 or so minutes into the presentation.
He has engaged in uh the standard fair
SDA proof texts, lots of assertions, and
knocking down a bunch of straw men. Um,
show me one verse in the Bible, lots of
uh verbatim fallacy type stuff. If you
didn't see part one, no need to pop over
there now, but some of what I might say
uh tonight might make some more sense if
you have seen that part. As a reminder,
yes, I know that not all Christians
agree with me, especially former
Adventists, and that's fine. But sharing
is caring. Like I said last time, the
purpose of both part one and two is not
to exhaustively cover every aspect of
the Sabbath, but to primarily focus on
the discussion within the context of two
parties that do happen to agree on
certain aspects, such as the Sabbath
being a creation ordinance, but disagree
on almost every other area.
um as he made the wild assertion that
many SDAs love to make which is that
there isn't a shred of biblical evidence
for Christians worshiping on the first
day to which we saw actually means there
isn't a single proof text in all of the
Bible that verbatim says go to church on
Sunday those sorts of things because
Doug has evidence for us that they don't
even understand the arguments and aren't
even in the conversation which Doug is
going to further evidence for us
tonight. Last week, he went through all
of the first day passages of scripture
as well as some uh rhetorical questions
asking a number of things like uh did
the apostles change it? Uh is well,
you're going to see he's actually going
to do a couple more here before he then
transitions into uh history.
If you are a former Adventist, lots of
this is going to sound very familiar to
you. some of the citations he's going to
bring up, you will most assuredly have
heard touted by some Adventist somewhere
before. But if you haven't actually
looked into those, you're in luck, cuz
tonight we will be. And we will see that
Doug's analysis of history is just as
bad as his handling of the biblical text
last week. With that said, let's get
back into it.
My uh how do Christians remember Jesus'
death? Is it a new Sabbath day or did
Christ give us something? And Bible
tells us that Romans chapter 6:3. Do you
not know that as many of us as were
baptized into Christ Jesus were baptized
into his death? Has Christ given us
something to remember his resurrection?
Yes. Is it a new Sabbath? No. What is
it? Baptism. Therefore, we were buried
with him through baptism into death.
Just as Christ was raised from the dead
by the glory of the father, even so we
should walk in a newness of life. The
death, burial, resurrection of the Lord
is not replaced by a new uh Sabbath day.
It is memorialized by baptism. Is a
reminder of the resurrection. Colossians
2:12, buried with him in baptism, in
which you also were raised with him
through faith in the working of God who
raised him from the dead. Isn't that
clear? Say amen. You're I think you're
very quiet today.
Did you catch the switcheroo?
He asked how Christians are to remember
Jesus's death and then said
resurrection.
No, Doug. Baptism isn't about
remembering Jesus's death. That is not
what Paul said in Romans 6. Nor does he
say baptism was given to remember the
resurrection.
That's not what was said in those
verses. Especially for people who
oftentimes are holding others, like we
showed last week, to the standard of the
verbatim fallacy.
There's nothing in there about a
memorial. Where's the word memorial in
there, Doug? Show me one verse in there
or one word in there where where it says
in that verse, memorial.
That's the standard you were holding us
to last week.
But first, the claim is not that the
first day is to remember Jesus's death
or resurrection, but redemption.
We went through that last week and and
ad nauseium on this platform at this
point,
which was accomplished by that work of
resurrection.
Not just that, but that was the final
step. And that brought about the new
creation. The creation that fell was
redeemed. which is why Exodus roots the
Sabbath in creation and Deuteronomy
roots it in redemption.
SDAs do not see this because they often
are not being taught to look at the
entirety of the biblical narrative or
when they can't even look at it without
the great controversy theme to do the
filtering for them, but instead they
look at it in small sound bites from all
over the place
that seem to to to fit with what they're
claiming or they think do like Doug just
did. Oh, it talks about baptism and
talks about us and so it baptism is a
memorial.
The the great controversy theme, folks,
completely obstructs the SDA mind from
being able to rightly see what Christ's
coming was actually about.
Because in their system, it wasn't to
accomplish redemption. No, it was
primarily to vindicate God against
accusations made by Satan in a pre-earth
existence.
And that process entails a seven-step
program. Seriously, their entire
sanctuary model of seven steps, which
Jesus is currently going through
himself, and he's at step five, the
investigative judgment. Until this
entire chain of stuff is complete, Jesus
is still working on redemption because
redemption actually revolves around
vindicating his character against the
accusations of a creature, namely Satan.
So because this is the case, they do not
understand what Jesus actually
accomplished in his perfect obedience in
a sinless life, death, burial, and
resurrection.
Which is again why we have not heard a
single mention of new creation yet. But
this is how interpretation works in
Adventism. The great controversy theme
is the lens through which everything in
scripture must be understood.
Paul hinges the entirety of the good
news on the person and work of Jesus
and hinges all of that on the
resurrection. 1 Corinthians 15. If he
didn't resurrect, it's all in vain.
He wasn't the Messiah. He wasn't the son
of God. Which is why in Romans uh 1:4 it
says the resurrection was the
demonstration that he was who he says he
was because if he would have remained in
the tomb it would have demonstrated he
was a sinner. He died just like everyone
else did and remained dead. But the fact
that he resurrected demonstrated he was
who he says he was. There's a lot that
hinges on this. And baptism does not
point to Jesus's resurrection.
Both the person and work of Christ hinge
on that final step.
But furthermore, Doug is simply
reiterating as expected.
Ellen White here, who claimed this in
spiritual gifts volume 1, notice, quote,
I saw that angels were filled with
amazement as they beheld the sufferings
and death of the king of glory. But I
saw that it was no marvel to the angelic
host that the Lord of life and glory,
who filled all heaven with joy and
splendor, should break the bands of
death and walk forth from his prison
house a triumphant conqueror. And if
either of these events should be
commemorated by a day of rest, it is the
crucifixion.
But I saw that neither of those events
were designed to alter or abolish God's
law, but they give the strongest proof
of its immutability.
Both of these important events have
their memorials.
By partaking of the Lord's supper, the
broken bread, and the fruit of the vine,
we show forth the Lord's death until he
comes. By observing this memorial, the
scenes of his sufferings and death are
brought fresh to our minds. The
resurrection of Christ is commemorated
by our being buried with him by baptism
and raised up out of the watery grave in
likeness of his resurrection to live in
newness of life. Close quote. So Doug is
basically just making the same claim.
She claimed to be shown by God that
neither the crucifixion or the
resurrection were designed to alter or
abolish the law, which first day
sabotarians are not claiming this.
And again, when the Adventist Church
makes these arguments against
Christians,
it's really only against first day
sabotarians at the end of the day
because other Christians don't even
agree on categorically the same thing
here. So these arguments basically just
have to be made against first day
sabotarians and they don't work. They're
it's irrelevant. But Doug made these
same assumptions like he did last week
that uh it just clearly shows an
erroneous understanding. It's not
claiming the law was abolished. But
nevertheless, the telltale sign that she
didn't receive this from God is that God
himself changes the form of the fourth
commandment in the second giving of the
law in Deuteronomy.
We looked at that last week. We've
looked at that countless times. We have
countless articles on this on the
website. Clearly, Ellen didn't know what
she criticized either,
and either did the person who supposedly
gave her this vision. But the point, as
you can see, she claims the resurrection
was memorialized by baptism, or is
rather, when no, it isn't. How could a
one-time ceremonial ordinance be how we
remember the resurrection? Like, they'll
claim the weekly Sabbath is how one
remembers the creator of heaven and
earth by virtue of it being weekly and
regularly occurring. But here they'll
point to a one-time event, baptism, to
say it memorializes the resurrection.
That's not how memorials work.
She's correct. The Lord's Supper in part
is a memorial of the death of Christ.
That's not all it is, but it is in part.
But even that doesn't function like a
memorial in Adventism. It's done every
13th week or something like that, like
four times a year, not weekly.
Nevertheless, baptism
is a sign and seal of regeneration. And
that's what Paul is getting at in Romans
6. Not that it's a memorial of the
resurrection. Notice what Charles uh
we're going to get back in Haj's
commentary here. We looked at him last
week in regards to 1 and 2 Corinthians,
but notice what he lays out here. And I
could have picked a number of people.
So speaking on Romans 6, this is from
his Romans commentary. He says, quote,
"As the gospel reveals the only
effectual method of justification, so
also it alone can secure the
sanctification of men. to exhibit this
truth is to uh is the object of this in
the following chapter. The sixth is
partly argumentative and partly
exorciatory.
In verses 1- 11, the apostle shows how
unfounded is the objection that
gratuitous justification meaning
justification freely given by God leads
to the indulgences of sin.
Get that Doug cited from verse from
Romans 6 3 and 4.
Hodgej points out which we're going to
look at in verses 1- 11. The apostle
shows how unfounded is the objection
that gratuitous justification leads to
the indulgences of sin. That is what is
in view in Romans 6.
In verses 12- 23, he exhorts Christians
to live agreeably to the nature and
design of the gospel and presents
various considerations adapted to secure
their obedience to this exhortation.
So notice folks, Paul is building an
argument and laying out a theology as
the book of Romans is unfolding. And the
reason we're going to dig in on this for
for a minute, even though this isn't a
super big point that he made, is it's
going to prove a bigger point of how the
SDA church is known to handle the Bible.
That will become much clearer as we go
along here. Chapters 1 through three
deal with the nature of fallen man and
the horrible condition he is in apart
from Christ, both Jew and Gentile alike.
Apart from Christ, all are unrighteous
and fall short of the glory of God.
That's the summation of ver of chapters
1 through 3.
Chapters four and five then deal with
the remedy to that problem. And he then
uses Abraham as an example, pointing to
Genesis 15.
He says Abraham was credited uh
righteousness when he believed God and
it was that faith in God, belief and
trust in him that justified him using
that as the example of the freely given
grace of or justification of God which
would mean justification has to do with
being seen as righteous in God's sight.
If Abraham was credited righteousness
based on his belief and he was
justified, that means that justification
has to do with righteousness in God's
sight. He then explains that this
justification brings a sinner to peace
with God. Romans 5:1. And then in five
through chapter 5, he then explains how
fallen man is born with uh the first
Adam as their representative. But when
one believes the gospel, they are
transferred from the fallen condemned
family of Adam into the righteous family
of Jesus Christ. Uh who as the second
Adam is then their new representative
that they are seen as righteous in
transfer from a kingdom of darkness to
kingdom of light. is a consistent theme
with Paul. He talks about this in 1
Corinthians as well, the the first Adam
and the second Adam, etc. It's 1
Corinthians 15.
But by the time he gets to chapter 6,
all of that has already been laid out.
That's the flow of where we're at in the
text. Now,
the apostle then transitions to the
objections that someone could bring to
what he's presented thus far.
namely that if it's the case that a
person is freely justified by faith
apart from works of the law then why
wouldn't someone just use that as a
license to sin he anticipates that
question he does this regularly
throughout Romans he does the same thing
in chapter 9
which is exactly why he starts 61 by
saying what shall we say then are we to
continue in sin that grace may abound by
no means how can we who died to sin
still live in it
So he asks this rhetorically as an
example of someone who might bring this
charge against what he just said. And
Hajj rightly points out that Paul in
verses 1-1 is refuting that charge by
explaining that the freely justifying
act of God upon a sinner does not
produce lentiousness
because there's far more to it than
that. It's not people are made a new
creature in Christ. They have new
desire. I mean there's all sorts of
things. They're born again. So
Paul is essentially squashing that. Now
notice what Hodgej points out in verses
3 and four which is what Doug cited
commenting on verse three. Know ye not
that so many of us as were baptized into
Jesus Christ were baptized into his
death? Hajdun comments, the apostle
reminds his readers that the very design
of Christianity was to deliver men from
sin. That everyone who embraced it
embraced it for that object and
therefore it was a contradiction in
terms to suppose that any should come to
Christ to be delivered from sin in order
that they might live in it.
And besides
or besides this, it is clearly intimated
that such is not only the design of the
gospel and the object of which it is
embraced by all who cordially receive
it, but also that the result or
necessary effect of union with Christ is
a particular or is a participation in
the benefits of his death. We're going
to read that again.
And besides this, it is clearly
intimated that such is not only the
design of the gospel and the object of
which it is embraced by all who coursely
receive it, but also that the result or
necessary effect of union with Christ is
a participation in the benefits of his
death.
So contrary to the SDA church often
claiming those Sunday Christians, they
don't believe in obedience. They don't
think Jesus actually frees people from
sin. They have a powerless gospel. Let
this be a testament that no, they're yet
again wrong. Christians disagree with
the SDA church's false doctrine around
sinless perfectionism, which then
results in them engaging in the false
dilemma fallacy of thinking if you
disagree with them, you must be
advocating for living it up in sin. As
if those are the only two options when
that's not the case at all. But Paul
here is laying out that baptism is a
sign and seal of having union with
Christ through his death. Hodgej
continues,
"When it is said that the Hebrews were
baptized unto Moses, 1 Corinthians 10:2,
or when the apostle asks the
Corinthians, were you baptized unto the
name of Paul?" 1 Corinthians 1:13. Or
when we are said to be baptized unto
Christ, the meaning is they were
baptized in reference to Moses, Paul, or
Christ, i.e. to be brought into union
with them as their disciples or
worshippers as the case may be. in like
manner in the expression baptized into
his death. The preposition expresses the
design and the result. The meaning
therefore is we were baptized in order
that we should die with him. I.e. that
we should be united to him in his death
and be partakers of its benefits.
Paul does not design to teach that the
sacrament of baptism from any inherent
virtue in the right or from any
supernatural power in him who
administers it or from any uniformity
attending divine influence always
secures the regeneration of the soul.
This is contrary both to this is
contrary both to scripture and
experience.
No fact is more obvious than that
thousands of the baptized are
unregenerate. It cannot be therefore
that the apostle intends to say that all
who are baptized are thereby savingly
united to Christ. It is not of the
efficacy of baptism as an external right
that he assumes his readers are
wellinformed.
It is of the import and design of that
sacrament and the nature of the union
with Christ of which baptism is the sign
and seal.
Close quote.
So by baptized into his death, Hodgej
argues that the grammar, remember the
only approved hermeneutic in the SDA
church, historical grammatical method.
Okay. Well, that's what Hodgej is
utilizing because that's where they got
this from.
Hajj argues argues that the grammar
expresses the idea of baptism being a
sign and seal of a person's union with
Christ. Now, not all Christians agree
with this, such as our Lutheran friends,
but the purpose of this was in showing
or the purpose in showing this was not
to convince you of the reformed
understanding of baptism, but to show
this verse has nothing to do with
baptism being a memorial of Jesus's
death.
Paul is transitioning to responding to
hypothetical arguments people could
bring up against what he said regarding
justification
such that if one is justified apart from
works, why not just live it up in sin so
grace can abound? He shuts that down by
stating that the true Christian united
to Christ was buried with him in baptism
and one who is truly united to Christ
doesn't have such a mindset.
He is pointing to baptism, the sign and
seal of union with Christ in his death
to highlight that
the same thing is being said by Paul in
Colossians 2, which actually shows the
connection between baptism in the new
covenant and circumcision in the old.
Like I said in part one, there are old
covenant forms, namely circumcision,
Passover, and the seventh day Sabbath.
In the new creation, those old covenant
forms take on new covenant forms.
Passover to the Lord's supper,
circumcision to baptism, 7th day Sabbath
to the first day Sabbath.
So no, Doug, it isn't clear that
Colossians 2 is saying that baptism is a
memorial of the resurrection.
And again, this whole presentation so
far, Doug has held others to the
verbatim fallacy. Yet neither of the
text that he appealed to, neither of
them use the word memorial.
And Doug, you still aren't utilizing the
HGM, which Ted Wilson told us is the
only approved hermeneutical method of
the SDA church. You just cite verses,
make assertions, and move along.
Romans 6 and Colossians 2 pose literally
zero problems for the Christian Sabbath
position.
But Colossians 2 actually does pose
serious issues for your guys' position,
as we're going to look at later since he
mentions it again. But Doug here is
beating up a straw man. He's seeking to
refute the claim that the first day is
not a memorial of Jesus's resurrection
when first day sabotarians do not claim
the first day is a memorial of the
resurrection. It is a memorial of the
new creation, the redemption, the work
that was accomplished by the Lord Jesus,
which the old sign again we talked about
in part one.
The seventh day pointed to that work
that would be accomplished just like
circumcision pointed to it, just like
Passover pointed to it, etc. When that
has come to pass, there are now new
forms in the new creation, in the new
covenant.
The resurrection was the turning point
from the old creation to the new. That's
why resurrection is pointed to and
celebrated.
But the root is in what the resurrection
demonstrates, which is that redemption
was accomplished and the new creation
has come.
Exodus 20 rooted in creation.
Deuteronomy 5 roots it in redemption.
That's exactly what it's still rooted
in. It just has a new form in the new
covenant.
And as was pointed out in the last part,
Adventists, the ceremonial form of the
fourth commandment not only can change,
but has changed multiple times in
scripture,
not just after man fell into sin, but
then in the second giving of the law in
Deuteronomy and then again in the new
creation.
So, how does the Bible refer to the
first day of the week? Is it a new
Sabbath?
Ezekiel 46:1, thus says the Lord God,
the gateway of the inner court that
faces towards the east shall be shut
during the six working days, but the
Sabbath it will be opened. The first day
of the week is called a what? It's a
regular working day. Now, you may be in
a country where you can actually uh be
prosecuted for breaking what they call
blue laws. There are some countries
where I know a lady, her father was put
in jail in Canada because he was out
working in his field on Sunday. Uh there
were times where you weren't allowed to
work on Sunday. The laws of men
again just breezes on over this, makes
an assertion. Oh, the first day is only
ever referred to as an ordinary normal
working day.
We got more appeals to the old creation
period prior to the redemption of
creation being accomplished. And then he
conflates that with the new creation
that we're in now. This is the problem
with the proof text method of
interpretation. Folks, they think they
have an infallible interpreter. They can
just consult her. I was just in Judle
Lake's book earlier, Ellen White under
fire, getting ready to do a stream on
that, and it it just it it blows my
mind. It he just multiple times in the
book, he just admits, yet SDAs will deny
this. Well, she's the lens through which
the Bible, you know, she she as the
lesser light, she's the lens that we're
to go to the Bible with, and then she
helps us really bring out the gems of
the Bible. We can really understand it.
Yeah. Right. She's the infallible
interpreter. Well, no. Okay. Well, then
that's what your Sabbath school
quarterly says. So, then we'll just
appeal to that where it verbatim says
the infallible book needs an infallible
interpretation in order to arrive at the
correct destination. So, but this is how
it works. They just cite these verses
because that's the approved thing from
either the guys at the BRRI or and and
they've consulted Ellen White or or you
know, what have you. But because that's
the case, well then it's just they know
it's biblical when no, they just do
these drivebys and make these
assertions.
They fail to look at the bigger picture
from Genesis to Revelation to see where
the narrative is going and what the real
substance actually is.
The only reason one would think these
verses somehow refutes the Christian
Sabbath position is if they don't
understand it, which Doug clearly
doesn't. And I think that's clear at
this point.
They assume the ceremonial form of the
command cannot change. Yet it does
change. Doug already admitted in part
one days were created. He claimed God
created the seventh day on the seventh
day.
Yet then he cites where Jesus said
Sabbath was made made for man, not
angels. They believe it's eternal. They
think the seventh day has an eternal
aspect to it to where it was being
observed prior to the creation of the
earth. Yet Doug claims the seventh day
was created on the seventh day.
It's like, do you guys listen to
yourselves? Days are dependent upon the
sun and moon, which are also a part of
creation.
Again,
all of the other all the other unfallen
worlds that they believe in,
they think they're all observing the Ten
Commandments.
So, are there like a bunch of parallel
timelines with like and then it's like
the seventh day here, but it's this it
could be a different
just crazy, man.
Think about this, folks. All these other
unfallen life forms on all the other
worlds they believe in, they all observe
the ten commandments supposedly. That's
why they're unfallen.
which would mean the seventh day wasn't
actually created like Doug claimed
because days were already in existence
even before the creation of the earth.
But in their minds, if you say the
ceremonial form of the command has
changed, you've changed something that's
immutable. When no, days are not
eternal. That's not the aspect of the
command that's eternal. The substance of
it is. And the substance of the fourth
commandment is that the one true God is
due worship, honor, and praise by virtue
of who he is.
He always has been, always will be
worthy of that. That's the eternal
aspect, not the seventh day.
They've taken the language of others,
which is why I get so worked up about
this, such as some of the Puritans, the
reformers, and then twisted what those
men were saying to try and say, "Well,
the SDA church just believes the same
thing those people did." when no,
none of them agreed that the seventh day
is some eternal unchanging thing or any
of this pre-earth origin story that
filters all of SDA theology.
The Puritans and reformers started with
scripture as the starting point, not the
great controversy which is then used to
interpret all of scripture. But then he
cites Ezekiel 46:1, another passage they
love.
Doug, that verse shows the pattern of
the command. six working days followed
by a Sabbath. It doesn't say Saturday.
It doesn't say Sunday.
He assumes his Roman calendar influence
and imports that into the text, failing
to see that what's in view is a pattern
and it was based on a memorial.
This is also in the old creation.
Christian sabotarians still follow that
same pattern, Doug. The memorial day has
simply shifted by virtue of Christ
accomplishing what the old one was
pointing to.
such that now in the new creation, we
are living in the substance of what the
type pointed to and the order is back to
how it was prefall.
We are back in right relationship with
God. We begin our week in communion with
him and then go out and subdue the earth
through our labors to God's glory. The
following six days repeat,
if you recall from part one, they loved
Doug brought this up. The seventh day
was around prior to the fall. Yeah.
God's seventh day, not man's.
man was fashioned informed on
preparation day and his first day based
on evening to evening was the seventh
day.
You guys missed this.
It moved to the end of man's week after
the fall because man's rest also became
cursed by the curse that was placed on
creation.
Christ comes and redeems and restores
what man lost and puts us back in right
relationship with God.
And all of that stuff ultimately points
to God's rest. We got into all that in
part one. He said, "What's the first day
of the week called? A regular working
day." Oh, really? Notice the feast of
boos in Leviticus 23.
The feast of boos was named that because
it was instituted to remember the
wilderness journey from Egypt to Canaan
when then when God made them live in in
boos.
And before we read this, remember the
Sabbath is rooted in rest, creation, and
redemption. those three things and we
see this unfolding in redemptive history
leading to the incarnation and God
himself coming who would restore the
creation that fell redeem it which
includes humanity since we are a part of
that and would then enter his rest God's
rest after that work was completed so
with that in mind notice Leviticus
23:33-43
and the Lord spoke to Moses saying speak
to the people of Israel saying on the
15th day of this seven month and For
seven days is the feast of boost to the
Lord. On the first day shall be a holy
convocation. You shall not do any
ordinary work. For seven days you shall
present food offerings to the Lord. On
the eighth day you shall hold a holy
convocation and present a food offering
to the Lord. It is a solemn assembly.
You shall not do any ordinary work.
These are the appointed feasts of the
Lord, which you shall proclaim as times
of holy convocation, for presenting to
the Lord food offerings, burnt
offerings, and grain offerings,
sacrifices, and drink offerings, each on
its proper day, besides the Lord's
Sabbaths, and besides your gifts, and
besides all your vow offerings, and
besides all your free will offerings,
which you give the Lord
on the 15th day of the seventh month,
when you have gathered in the produce of
the land, you shall celebrate the feast
of the Lord. ward seven days. On the
first day shall be a solemn rest, and on
the eighth day shall be a solemn rest.
And you shall take on the first day the
fruit of the splendid of splendid trees,
branches upon branches, and boughs of
leaf trees, and willows of the brook.
And you shall rejoice before the Lord
your God seven days. That's what they
used to actually build their booths
with. You shall celebrate it as a feast
to the Lord for seven days in the year.
It is a statute forever throughout your
generations. You shall celebrate it in
the seventh month. You shall dwell in
boos for seven days. All native
Israelites shall dwell in boos that your
generations may know that I made the
people of Israel dwell in boos when I
brought them out of the land of Egypt. I
am the Lord your God. Thus the reading
of God's holy word. So the SDA church is
wrong when they claim there were two
laws. God's law and Moses's law. No,
Moses was a mediator, a conduit
messenger between God and the people. He
was a picture of Christ who is the
better mediator than Moses. That's what
Hebrews 3 is talking about.
But it was all God's law. Nevertheless,
Doug, there you go. The first day is
said to not only be holy in some
instances but no ordinary work was to be
done on the feast of booze which
occurred on the first day showing that
the holiness aspect around any day is
tied to obeying God not some sort of
ethereal divinity that a day of a week
that the day of a week possesses.
They'll dismiss this as simply being a
festival as if that negates the point.
It doesn't. This is a type and shadow of
the substance which is Christ. The new
covenant creation was anticipated in the
Old Testament feast days by the eighth
day Sabbath which pointed figurative
figuratively to Christ. We got into that
some last time.
The new creation by the way was also
anticipated by the Jubilee year which
was the year after the seventh seven.
So again, eight Christ declared himself
to be the fulfillment of the Jubilee in
Luke 4 uh 4:19,
which is why every Sunday is a is the
day after the 7th, like a almost like a
miniature jubilee.
But also notice it says this festival is
to be a statute forever.
Yet SDA's love appealing to places like
Ezekiel, which say the same thing about
the Sabbath being forever to try and
bolster their position. Oh, it's going
to be observed in heaven, brother.
Isaiah 66.
Yet, they don't think the feast of booze
will be observed in eternity.
And as you'll see in a moment, they
don't they don't observe the festivals
and ceremonial aspects and claim they
were nailed to the cross when no, the
festivals are actually kept now by being
in Jesus, who's the substance of them.
That includes the feast of booths. No
law was nailed to the cross.
But I guess that would mean something
that is said to be forever
doesn't mean it will always have the
same form it once had. In fact, to be
consistent with their whole the
ceremonial law was nailed to the cross
line, they would have to then recognize
that something that is said to be
forever can be done away with.
Nevertheless, this is a perfect example
that no, when the SDA church claims that
God never called any other day holy,
they are wrong. It's right there, Doug.
Redemption out of slavery is exactly
what the feast of booths is about.
The first day, redemption,
Egypt, Deuteronomy 5, the second giving
of the law, the form of the fourth
commandment changing. Are you getting
all the connections, folks? No. No. No.
They have no biblical They have no
biblical support. No, we're just not on
spiritual milk all the time. You got to
get past that, folks. You got to get
past that. And this idea of the silly
standard that they like to whip out. Oh,
where? Show me one verse in the Bible
that says, "Yeah, okay. That's not going
to work out very well when you
internally use that same standard
because you're not supposed to use
unjust weights and measures like the
proverbs say.
Redemption out of slavery is exactly
what the feast of booths is about. This
is a foreshadowing of our redemption,
which again is one of the three things
that the Sabbath is rooted in. Creation,
redemption, and rest.
The the Israelites were to remember the
true God of heaven and earth. That's
creation. Remember their redemption that
he ultimately led. That's redemption.
And they were to rest in doing so.
That's the rest. This took place on the
first day. It's all right there, sir.
You guys love typology supposedly. There
you go.
The exodus out of slavery was
typological of our bondage and slavery
to sin. And Jesus as the better Joshua
and Moses led us out in a better pro to
a better promised land. the heavenly
Mount Zion, the better rest by a better
mediator, a better Joshua that led a
better redemption. We've looked at
Hebrews 3 and 4 before many times, which
lays all that out.
But it's this sort of hopscotching
around the Bible in little sound bites.
That's Doug's problem. You don't
actually look at the substance or theme
of the narrative of scripture and the
bigger picture of what's going on. So
you have to resort to to conspiracy
theories and just ridiculous assertions
to try and say we have no remember last
week we have no rhyme or reason for what
we do. We're just like a guard standing
post that just inherited a tradition and
we have no idea why we're doing what
we're doing. This is after he used the
hasty generalization fallacy by saying
he went to a couple pastors locally that
couldn't give him an answer to the
subject on the Sabbath, so therefore
Christians just have no basis. No, Doug,
you just didn't look hard enough. Now,
he's going to go into full-blown
historical revisionism mode. Buckle up.
So, if Sunday keeping isn't in the
Bible, and I think I tried to establish
that, where did it come from?
Well, it comes from just as the name
implies, sun worship.
Uh, for years in Rome, and they get it
from the Babylonians, and it goes all
the way back to Egypt. One of their
principal gods was Rah, the god of the
sun. And around the ancient world, they
understood something miraculous happened
with photosynthesis.
When the days get longer and when the
sun shines, plants come out, life comes
out, the other animals and herbivores do
better and all of a sudden everything
springs into life by virtue of sun. They
understood there's a mystery there.
Photosynthesis is an amazing thing. We
even get electricity from sunlight now,
don't we? Solar panels, right? So they
they knew there was power in the sun,
but instead of worshiping the one that
made the sun, they started worshiping
the sun. And Moses said, "Do not lift up
your eyes and worship the sun, the moon,
and the stars like the heathen do."
By the time of Christ in Rome, there sun
worship was one of their principal gods.
And um what was gradually happening is
as the church grew eventually by the
time of Paul there were soon more
Gentiles believing in Christ than there
were Jews.
And pretty soon there were a lot more
Gentiles in the church than Jews. And
the Gentiles wanting to reach their
pagan friends they said let's make as
many accommodations as we can to try to
reach them. And so for a while in Rome
they actually they worshiped the day of
the sun on the first day of the week and
um many Christians they worshiped on the
Sabbath. They said you know we'll get a
lot more of them to join our church if
we will also recognize Sunday. They
thought they were being evangelistic
and it came in like a Trojan horse. The
Jews were very unpopular. You realize
that 70 AD the Romans destroyed
Jerusalem for the rebellion and it was a
very expensive war. You know the Romans
had to fight three years against Msada
and it was a very expensive war. The the
Romans were so tired of the Jews that
when they finally conquered Jerusalem
they decimated the people. It was a
terrible siege. The Christians wanting
to distance themselves from the Jews who
had become very unpopular
and they thought they were legalistic.
They said, 'Well, we we actually we
worship on the Lord's day. And because
Jesus rose on the first day of the week,
and they started to manufacture theology
that had no Bible basis at all. Let me
go on and prove this to you. Matthew
15:9, "And in vain they worship me,
teaching the doctrines of the
commandments of men." Now, I got to say
something right here. Are there going to
be a lot of people in heaven that went
to church on Sunday? Millions.
Millions and millions of Sundayeping
Christians are going to be there because
they did not know. Are there going to be
people in heaven that own slaves?
You don't want to say yes, but you know
it's true. Otherwise, you just kicked
Abraham out of heaven, right? And David
and Jacob. Are there going to be people
in heaven that had multiple wives at one
time?
Yes.
God winks at the times of ignorance, but
when we know the truth, we need to walk
in the church. So yes, there's going to
there's good I believe there are
spiritfilled godly Christian
heaven-bound people in many Sunday
churches that maybe don't understand
these things. Sin is knowing to do good
and not doing it. The Bible says if we
continue in sin after we receive a
knowledge of the truth, Hebrews chapter
10 26, there is no more sacrifice. And
so when we understand and then we say
I'm going to do what tradition says
instead of what the word of God says,
that's serious then.
So, we got the whole kitchen sink right
there, and he's going to keep going. But
Doug, you most certainly did try to
establish that Sunday Keeping isn't in
the Bible. But you didn't do so. You
failed. You simply cited, like you
always do, a smattering of classic SDA
proof texts, made zero mention of the
new creation, which is the central
aspect of the entire discussion. You
bore false witness about Christians, and
now you go on to do more of that.
You utilized an inconsistent hermeneutic
where you regularly appealed to the
verbatim fallacy that every doctrine has
to be verbatim stated or it isn't
present even though your guys's entire
system would collapse if you held that
standard across the board for all of
your own novel doctrines.
So first he made the ridiculous sun
worship charge which has to be one of
their most desperate attempts.
Again, if Doug had held a consistent
standard, you all are now Saturn
worshippers, right? It's just silly that
you guys still try this. But Christians,
notice that ancient Christians dealt
with this same silly charge in their
day.
Notice what Tertullian says in his book
to the nations. quote
others with greater regard to good
manners. He's writing against uh people
that are coming up against Christians of
the day.
So he's essentially doing apologetics
here. Quote, "Others with great regard
to good manners, it must be confessed,
suppose that the sun is the god of the
Christians because it is a well-known
fact that we pray toward the east or
because we make Sunday a day of
festivity."
What then? Do you do less than this? Do
not many among you with an affection of
sometimes worshiping the heavenly bodies
likewise move your lips in the direction
of the sunrise.
It is you at all events who have even
admitted the sun into the calendar of
the week. And you have selected its day
in preference to the preceding day as
the most suitable in the week for either
an entire abstinence from the bath or
for its postponement until the evening
or for taking a rest and for banqueting.
By resorting to these customs, you
deliberately deviate from your own
religious rights to those of strangers.
For the Jewish feast on the Sabbath, the
Jewish Yeah. For the Jewish feast on the
Sabbath, and the purification, and the
Jewish also are the ceremonies of the
lamps, and the fast of the unle of
unleavened bread, and the literal
prayers, and all which institutions and
practices are, of course, foreign from
your gods, wherefore that I may return
from this digression, you who approach
us with the sun and Sunday, should
consider your proximity to us. We're not
far off from your Saturn and your days
of rest.
Close quote.
So regardless of your views regarding
Tullon,
this is long before Constantine.
This charge by Doug is not only silly,
but old.
And Teroleian's final sentence there is
exactly the point. Now, he's he's
responding to pagans here, and he's
trying to say, "Well, you pagans, you
almost look like not just us, but the
Jews as well."
But you who claim we're worshiping the
sun should consider the fact that by
that same silly standard, you're
worshiping Saturn.
The fir the the the Christian church
worshiping on the first day has
absolutely zip zero nada to do with
photosynthesis and Babylonians having
mystical views regarding the nature of
the sun in the sky having some sort of
powers.
There are literally zero connections
between the two.
Nothing Doug said here has anything to
do with why Christians corporately
gather on the first day.
He ironically talks about us being the
ones who worship the sun when the
reality is they worship a day by giving
it a divine-like characteristic that the
seventh day is literally eternal.
Even though he just said earlier it was
created
and days are a product of the sun and
the moon. Notice here Tertullian doesn't
tie anything intrinsic to the day
Sunday. He even talks about the pagans
are the ones that named it that. I don't
we don't care what you call it.
No, Doug, you guys worship the creation,
not us.
We meet on the day as a memorial of what
occurred on that day, not because of
some divine characteristic that the day
supposedly has and it's been with God
eternally forever.
Then he blamed early Gentile Christians
and said that they were seeking to
compromise and make accommodations for
evangelistic reasons.
Folks, what you what you have here,
all of all of what he said pretty much
total fiction. Total fiction. Story time
with Doug Bachelor. Make believe.
Has nothing to do with the new creation.
The Gentiles wanting to seek to be
evangelistic and that just kind of took
over because they hated Jews. They love
that excuse. Well, it's cuz they hated
Jews.
So now Satan in the great controversy
was supposedly using early gentile
converts to mislead people by trying to
be evangelistic and tell them they could
worship the sun on Sunday as a
Christian. And this then took off such
that the entirety of the Christian
church in both the east and the west
adopted the practice.
I I mean can we just apply AAM's razor
here?
Like it can't be the obvious answer. It
has to be this like, no, no, no. It's
this serious crazy conspiracy.
Even though we sent people like Samuel
Bakyoki to to try and find the the proof
for this and we we couldn't really find
it earlier than um um you know what we
attested, but ignore all that. Okay.
If it hasn't become clear at this point
that he has no clue what he's
criticizing, I'm not sure what else will
demonstrate it. He breezed over proof
text while making assertions,
misrepresented the position, utilized
hasty generalization fallacy by claiming
that since he went down to some pastors
down the street who didn't have a strong
understanding on the Sabbath and the
role it plays in redemptive history,
that means Christians as a whole have no
basis.
Now he's literally just paring complete
fiction to tack on to all of that.
Notice he says the early Christians
sought to distance themselves from the
Jews because they were legalistic.
when no the fact is they rejected Jesus
and we have no fellowship with anyone
who does so. Anyone that denies Christ
is King of Kings, Lord of Lords, God in
the flesh, the Messiah is Antichrist.
Paul goes scorched earth in Galatians
over Judaizers that were adding
circumcision to the gospel.
And to make sure he makes himself clear,
he says he hopes that when they go to
perform the action, their hand slips,
the whole thing comes off.
But you use your imagination there.
So if by legalistic you mean they were
heretical and distorted the gospel of
the Lord Jesus Christ leading to a false
gospel that's cursed and can't save
anyone, then sure.
But the reality is many SDAs say this
sort of stuff because they try and claim
the 7th day Sabbath was abandoned
because early Christians hated Jews when
no like Paul they hated Judaizing
which distorts the gospel. It's a
rejection of Jesus
which is exactly what the SDA church has
unknowingly done
and it produces a false cursed gospel.
The Judaizers in Galatia said, "If you
want to come to Christ, you have to be
circumcised to do so." The SDA church
says, "If you want to come to Christ,
you have to do so on the 7th day
Sabbath."
On top of a truckload of other additions
they've added to the gospel that have
nothing to do with the gospel,
Jesus began the practice of corporate
gathering on the first day with the
apostles post his resurrection.
We saw that in the last part. We have
zero dated and documented cases of Jesus
keeping the seventh day post his
resurrection. What we do have are dated
corporate gatherings all on the first
day in the New Testament.
The apostles then continued this
practice after the 40 days and of of
Jesus ascending after his 40 days and
ascending
which is also what Ignatius a disciple
of John the Apostle tells us happened.
So both history and scripture are
against you on this, Doug.
And you bore false witness again, by the
way.
He claimed our manufactured theology is
not in the Bible. Not only is that
ironic considering your entire movement
is built on a novel manufactured
doctrine to cover up a disappointment in
the 19th century, but you haven't even
mentioned new creation a single time.
It's totally manufactured. But I don't
even know what your arguments are.
You haven't even demonstrated that you
know what we believe. Matthew 15 has
nothing to do with the new creation
being inaugurated and Jesus entering his
rest on the first day. That's not
talking about that again, Doug. You
didn't use the HGM when you pulled up
Matthew 15 there. You just brought up
I'm going to prove it to you after you
give this whole historical revisionism.
You then cite a single proof text and
say, "See, that proves it. It's it's the
Bible says so."
Laughable.
Jesus restored what man tarnished in the
garden where even the rest of man was
cursed. But no, no, no, no biblical
basis. Just totally manufactured out of
thin air. Doug, you guys are the last
ones that should be talking about extra
biblical manufactured theology. The
entire great controversy worldview is
extra biblical manufactured theology.
The investigative judgment is entirely
novel manufactured theology. Your guy's
entire movement is built on man-made
manufactured theology hidden behind the
veneer of it's just the Bible. Jud Lake
was talking about that in his book too,
citing old people around s uh uh the
pioneers days and he's like citing these
people and there's one quote in there. I
don't remember who it's from, but this
person was basically saying like, oh, it
was Uriah Smith. He's giving an analogy
that like if you were out on a ship and
you were you had the you had the the
guide, but then things became tumultuous
and a storm came and and the the author
of the book sent a a pilot to you to
tell you how to navigate through the
storm. Are you going to reject the
pilot? Basically saying that like Ellen
White was given during these tumultuous
end times to make clear the you know the
path for the destination etc. And he
essentially says if you reject her it's
just evidence that you don't actually
believe the Bible. You don't believe the
Bible in whole. If you do you'll just
accept her constant just
wow. Now, I responded a few weeks ago to
Doug and the SDA church's claim that of
course there'll be there'll be a lot of
of Sunday keepers in heaven. Remember
what they mean by this. Christians,
they always bring this up when doing
this, bearing false witness campaign on
this subject. No, no. We believe lots of
Sunday keepers will be in heaven. Aka
they were saved in ignorance before God
gave them light through Ellen White to
share with the world, which if you hear
and reject, you'll be lost. That's what
they mean by that. You can go watch that
video for more on that. It's titled Doug
Bachelor butchers the Bible.
No, Doug. Those of us that have studied
this out deeply understand just fine. We
aren't in ignorance. This idea that
everyone was in the dark on the Sabbath
until you guys came along is laughable.
Theologians for 2,000 years have been
discussing this and have known about
your guys's claims because they're not
unique to you on this subject. Judaizers
have been around for a long time.
Adventism,
Adventism's claim to novelty is the
investigative judgment, not the seventh
day Sabbath.
You guys just resurrected a bunch of
ancient heresy.
No pun intended.
And you were talking about kicking
people out of heaven like Abraham. Sir,
you guys kick Ignatius, Justin Martyr,
Tutoleian, Cyprian, Yibius, and hordes
of of gifts that God gave the church out
of heaven because they weren't ignorant
on this subject.
So, you can't use that excuse
because they understood what you call
the Sabbath truth and they rejected it
because they understood scripture in the
new creation. But then we got the
butchering of Hebrews 10. Again, this
guy does this. He just shotguns out
verses and it's like, "Oh, wow. Look,
he's citing all sorts of the Bible. And
because they're just citing it, Jed Lake
talks about that in his book as well.
Merlin Bert went through and looked at
how many times she cites the Bible and
patriarchs and prophets and prophets and
kings. Who cares? That's not exposition.
Who gives a rip?
All sorts of people just cite the Bible.
That doesn't mean anything.
So, just like that, you just did the
same thing. And that's what Doug does
all the time. He just cites verses and
oh because he cites so many verses. Wow,
it's so biblical.
Hebrews 10 that this verse somehow
supports if you hear about the SDA
Sabbath truth and reject it, there no
longer remains a sacrifice for sins for
you. That's essentially how he's
applying this here, Doug. But if you
guys consistently applied this verse
this way, then everyone would be lost
because the author says there no longer
remains a sacrifice for sins after
having received a knowledge of the
truth. Since you guys ignore the
context, which is about Jewish converts
being tempted to go back to the old
covenant sacrificial system in this
particular chapter, the whole book is
addressing them wanting to go back to
the old types and shadows. But here he's
specifically talking about those tempted
to go back to the sacrificial system.
But because you ignore that, you turn
the verse into basically saying that if
anyone has sinned since knowing
something was wrong, they're doomed.
Yet, that isn't what's being said.
Ironically, it's referring to Judaizing
because the author has already explained
earlier in chapter 10 and in previous
chapters that Jesus is the final
sacrifice.
He was writing to Hebrew Christians
prior to to 70 AD because the temple was
apparently still standing to be able to
go back and do those things.
So he's pointing out how Jesus is better
than all of the shadows.
And again in this paricopy he's
specifically dealing with how Jesus is
the better sacrifice, the final
sacrifice. And to go back to the animal
sacrifices is to trample underfoot the
blood of the son of God who is that
final sacrifice. And that's why there
remains no there there no longer remains
a sacrifice for sins. They can't go and
sacrifice animals anymore. There is no
more of that.
The author is exhorting people to cling
to Christ and not return to shadows.
Nothing to do with supposedly hearing in
this case the Adventist Sabbath truth.
And if you reject it, you'll be lost. It
just assumes you guys are correct. It
doesn't demonstrate it.
If Doug utilized the only approved
hermeneutic of the SDA church, the HGM,
he would understand this. But hopscotch
exes Jesus allows you to make this text
say whatever you want, and all sorts of
people do.
But also, Doug, the law had entire
categories for unintentional sins.
You guys have created your own standard
of what sin God does and doesn't hold
people accountable for.
It isn't disobedience to worship
corporately on the first day Christian.
That's the core issue.
Adventists think Christians are in
disobedience in this area and we aren't.
Once that's once that is distin is
extinguished.
This whole idea completely collapses.
And it isn't that the majority of people
are ignorant and God's just winking at
their sin and ignorance as they cling to
a tradition.
The earliest recognition of the
observance of Sunday, it's a
constitution of Constantine in 321 AD
enacting that all the courts of justice
and inhabitants and towns and the
workshops were to rest on Sunday. Here's
the decree of Constantine on the
venerable day of the sun. Is that s like
son of god or is it su n like sun in the
sky? It's the sun. See, Constantine knew
the Romans still were involved in sun
worship. First day of the week, that's
where it gets its name. You know where
Monday gets its name? Monday in Spanish,
lunes, right? Which is that's where you
get lunatic. It's true. They people
thought with full moon people went
crazy. And um the different days of the
week were named after the different
Greco Roman gods. And somewhere a Viking
god got in there. Thursday was Thor's
day, but uh Wednesday was Odin's day.
Friday was Freda, Saturday Saturn. And
so they were named after the different
heavenly gods and the pagan gods. So he
says, "On the venerable day of the sun,
let the magistrates and the people
residing in the cities rest. Let all the
workshops be closed." It was to be a
Sabbath, but they did give permission
for the farmers to milk their goats and
do their farm work on Sunday.
The church made a sacred day of Sunday
largely because it was the weekly
festival of the sun for it was a
definite Christian policy to take over
the pagan festivals endeared to the
people by tradition and to give them a
Christian significance Arthur Wiggle
paganism in our Christianity. The author
of this is not a member of my church.
He's just writing history. Another
example of that they started to allow
idolatry because they said look the
pagans all love their idols. They got
their idols of Venus and A
um
what is it called? Athena, um Mercury,
Apollos, Jupiter, and um so they just
said Mary, Peter, James, John, and they
they gave them all Christian names. They
said, "Well, we it'll make it easier for
them to transition. We want to make it
easy." So, they compromised to try and
make it easy for them to join the
church. And they started to pretty soon
they gave up the Bible Sabbath and the
church leaders say we will feast on
Sunday made it very attractive to the
pagans to come in but we will fast on
the Sabbath.
Now after a while uh fasting on the
seventh day feasting on the first day
which day would you enjoy?
You can see that over time the Sabbath
became very unpopular because first of
all they said it was it's the Jewish
Sabbath and and then they started to uh
say oh we feast on Sunday and gradually
it was abandoned
by the fifth century Selman stated that
most churches such as Constantinople met
both on Sabbath the first day and
Saturday evening
uh but that in Roman Alexandria met only
on the first day Saturday evening and no
longer on the Sabbath. So you start
tracking the history and the the church
fathers say that there was a gradual
transition had nothing to do with the
teachings of Jesus or the apostles. It
is a man-made tradition that God's
people have drifted from the
commandments of God. But in the last
days we should be returning.
Doug, you are full of it and you have no
clue what you're talking about.
Like I said in the first part, my
challenge still stands. I don't think
you'll take me up on it.
I challenge you to a debate on this,
sir.
Bring your Bible. I'll bring my Bible.
I'll come all the way out to California.
I'll come on your territory in Granite
Bay. Let's do it at your church.
See, you back this claim up, buddy.
Again, we got more of the whole kitchen
sink here.
So, we've seen and addressed this claim
before. Constantine.
So, if you've been watching for a while,
you should know how Doug twisted both
the Encyclopedia Bratannica as well as
their favorite source to site, Philip
Schoff's history of the Christian
church.
Folks that have been here for a while,
are those ringing a bell? You remember
when we've looked at those before?
because they all parrot these same
sources but haven't actually read what
they're citing from clearly. First,
let's look at Shaw's book. Again, I have
this book.
We're going to look at the exact same
chapter that Doug cited from and see
what Dr. Shaw is saying. Notice
quote the observance of Sunday
originated in the time of the apostles
and ever since forms the basis of public
worship with its enabling sanctifying
and cheering influences in all Christian
lands. Pause. From the time of when
the apostles,
not Sylvester the Pope, not Constantine,
not the council of Leodysa, the
apostles. He continues the Christian
Sabbath, Lord's day, first day, etc. is
on the one hand the continuation and the
regeneration of the Jewish Sabbath based
upon God's resting from the creation and
upon the fourth commandment of the
decalogue which as to its substance
is not of merely national application
like the ceremonial and civil law but of
universal import and perpetual validity
for mankind.
It is on the other hand a new creation
of the gospel, a memorial of the
resurrection of Christ and of the work
of redemption completed and divinely
sealed thereby.
Adventists will point to that and say,
"See, Schoff said it was a memorial of
the resurrection of Christ."
Yeah, it's not what you think he means.
some new creation.
It rests, we may say, upon the
three-fold basis of the original
creation, the Jewish legislation, and
the Christian redemption, and is rooted
in the physical, the moral, and the
religious wants of our nature.
It has a legal and an evangelical
aspect.
Like the law in general, the institution
of the Christian Sabbath is a wholesome
restraint upon the people and a school
master to lead them to Christ.
But it is also strictly evangelical. It
was originally made for the benefit of
man like the family with which it goes
back beyond the fall to the paradise of
innocence as the second institution of
God on earth. It was a delight to the
pious of the old dispensation. And now
under the new, it is fraught with the
glorious memories and blessings of
Christ's resurrection and the outpouring
of the Holy Spirit.
That's really what Shaw is getting at
when he talks about the memorial. Again,
it's all tied in redemption, the new
creation.
The Christian Sabbath is the ancient
Sabbath baptized with fire and the Holy
Ghost regenerated, spiritualized, and
glorified. It is the connecting link of
creation and redemption, of paradise
lost and paradise regained, and a pledge
and preparation for the saints
everlasting rest in heaven. Close quote.
All things that I've said before, but
said a lot more scholarly.
Christian Sabbath is rooted in the new
creation, not the old. The seventh day,
seventh day Sabbath was the memorial of
the old fallen creation that needed to
be redeemed. It pointed to the new
creation and eternal rest. Jesus Christ
accomplished redemption upon his
resurrection with the new memorial
pointing to that which then also points
us to the eternal rest.
Sha continues
in this matter as in others the
ascension or the assession of
Constantine marks the beginning of a new
era and it did good service to the
church and to the cause of public order
and morality.
Constantine. Get this folks.
Constantine is the founder in part at
least of the civil observance of Sunday
by which alone the religious observance
of it in the church could be made
universal and could be properly secured.
Oh shoot. Sorry folks. I just realized
that uh
I was on the wrong slide there. Sorry
about that.
In the year 321, he issued a law
prohibiting manual labor in the cities
and all judicial transactions at a later
period also militarily exercises or
military exercises on Sunday. He
exempted the liberation of slaves which
was an act of Christian humanity and
charity might with special propriety
take place on that day.
Close quote.
So there was a civil and religious
aspect, two different things.
The civil had to do with the legalities
around what the government did and did
not recognize.
That was not the religious aspect which
the church was already practicing.
This civil observance had to do with the
empire recognizing Christianity as a
valid and legal religion.
This was an action taken by Constantine
to protect Christians, not co-mingle or
co-opt paganism with Christianity,
which is why Schoff then says,
"But the Sunday law of Constantine must
not be overrated.
He enjoined the observance or rather
forbade the public desecration of Sunday
not under the name of Sabbatham or Das
domini but under its old astrological
and heathen title Das Solus familiar to
all his subjects so that the law was as
applicable to the worshippers of
Hercules, Apollos and Mithris as to
Christians.
There is no reference whatsoever in his
law either to the fourth commandment or
to the resurrection of Christ. Besides,
he expressly exempted the the country
districts where paganism still prevailed
from the prohibition of labor and thus
avoided every appearance of injustice.
Christians and pagans had been
accustomed to festival feasts. Now get
this.
Constantine made these rests to
synchronize and gave the preference to
Sunday on which day Christians from the
beginning celebrated the resurrection of
their Lord and Savior. This and no more
was implied in the inf or in the famous
enactment of 3:21.
Close quote.
Ah so the Sunday law of Constantine
cannot be overrated.
His law legalized Christianity and
forbade the public desecration of
Sunday. And from the beginning,
Christians were celebrating the memorial
of the new creation, the day Christ
accomplished his redemptive work and
entered his rest the first day.
Doug, if you actually read Shaw and the
chapter from where you cited,
you'd know that you just abused what
Shaw is saying because he explicitly
says to not do what you just claimed,
evidencing, you haven't even read what
you're citing from.
This particularly irks me because day in
and day out I get to hear from SDAs, you
don't know where you're citing from. The
irony. The irony.
You made zero distinction, Doug, between
civil and ceremonial.
Constantine did not enact a religious or
ceremonial law. It was civil. Yes, that
matters
because Doug tries taking the civil
enactment and then conflates it with the
religious practice.
The religious practice was already
happening before Constantine. The same
shaft tells you it originated with the
apostles.
And Ignatius's historical account tells
us John which
let's see a disciple of one of the
apostles or somebody 19 generations
removed whose whose testimony is going
to be more accurate and more reliable
regarding what the apostles were
practicing and doing. That also then
jives with the New Testament and all of
the dated cases that we have of when
Jesus corporately gathered with the
body. And Ignatius tells us they were
doing this because Jesus started this
with them. And then it's dated and
documented for us in scripture. And it's
those are the only ones that are dated
and documented.
There's no grand conspiracy.
You guys have to find that though. So
you have to just pull from over here and
just throw the whole kitchen sink out
there and make these wild lazy
assertions that are just laughable in in
in the 21st century.
Doug even recognized
that this was long before Constantine.
Less than five minutes ago, he claimed
Gentiles were trying to distinguish
themselves from Jews and it was based on
man-made manufactured theology
supposedly. Yet now it's because of
Constantine and the sun gods supposedly.
Well, it started with them there and
then they were trying to be evangel
evangelistic and then with Constantine,
it really ramped up. And
Doug, you made the same error your
pioneer JH Wagner did, of whom I'm going
to guess you borrowed this from, just
like Mark Finley did, and it backfires.
from his book titled The Origin and
Growth of Sunday Observance in the
Christian Church. First, look at what he
admits and then watch how he twists
what's actually being said by Dr. Schoff
just like Doug did, citing the exact
same thing.
First, he says, "Dr. Schoff is justly
esteemed as a man of extensive learning
and whose testimony regarding facts no
one would call into question.
He is a theologian and a warm friend of
Sundaykeeping,
but but his theological relations have
not prevented his giving the facts into
the first Sunday law. Close quote.
Shoff said the the first day started
with who?
The apostles.
No one could call into question Sha's
extensive learning and testimony
regarding the facts in this area.
Okay.
The same man here that we're going to
see
that worshiping Sunday originated with
the apostles shafted
and who said that Constantine's edict
cannot be overrated and used to weasle
in all these extra conspiracies
that it was to protect Christians. It
wasn't a melding of paganism with
Christianity.
This this guy here is now going to quote
Sha's book just like Doug did. Notice
what he says.
He says, so now he's quoting from Sha
here. He enjoined the observance or
rather forbade the public desecration of
Sunday. Oh, what do you know? This is
what we just read, right? Not under the
name of Sabbathom or Das Deini, but
under its own ast or yeah, under its own
astrological or heathen title, Das
Solus, familiar to all his subjects, so
that the law was as applicable to the
worshippers of Hercules, Apollo, or
Mithus as to the Christians. Close
quote. That's where he ends it.
And indeed, it was more applicable to
the worshippers of Hercules, Apollo, or
Mithus than to Christians, for it
referred to heathen and not at all to
Christian worship.
Is that why Shaw was was citing the
pagan names and and why Constantine
synchronized things the way that he did?
He continues again. Dr. Sha says he
enjoined the civil observance of Sunday,
though not as deas domini, but as Das
Soloulless, in conformity to his worship
of Apollo, and in company with an
ordinance for the regular consultation
of the Harrispex 3:21.
Concerning its claim to be considered a
sacred day, it's not necessary to add
much to what has already been said by
the writers quoted. It would be
presumption in the extreme to claim that
God ever conferred any blessing or
sanctification directly upon it by a
system of false reasoning. They try to
make out that the blessing that was
conferred upon the seventh day was
transferred to the first. But of course,
no scriptures ever quoted to justify the
claim. The authorities here given say
that it was dedicated to the sun and
that dedication is its only claim to
sanctity. Close quote.
So, now that we buried that guy because
you can see he's straight up lying or
doesn't know what he's talking about.
Bologoney.
Just like Doug, this guy has no clue
what he's criticizing. And if he
actually read Shaw, he would have seen
the Christian Sabbath has nothing to do
with the transference of Saturday to
Sunday or instit or or uh an institution
of a religious observance of Sunday.
The same guy he assured us couldn't be
questioned when it came to the facts of
history regarding the subject.
He would have seen
what we read and that he explicitly said
Constantine can't be overplayed like the
SDA church has done.
His edict had everything to do with
Christians and protecting them, not the
heathen. It wasn't about dedicating the
day to the sun. Wagner is twisting
Shaw's words to say the exact opposite
of what he was saying, just like Doug
did.
The name simply had to do with the
astrological calendar. Not because of
the pagans, not because of worshiping
the sun or melding Christianity with
paganism.
And it had no, as as Sha rightly pointed
out, it had nothing to do with
transference of anything from one day to
another, the Ten Commandments, etc.
They both partially quoted Schoff out of
context. Only the portions that make it
appear like Sha is agreeing with his his
their contortions when in reality that
isn't at all what Shaw is saying. Now
let's look at the Encyclopedia
Bratannica regarding the edict of Milan
since he cited that also. By he I mean
Doug.
Notice perfectly in line with Dr.
quote
edict of Milan proclamation that
permanently established religious
toleration for Christianity within the
Roman Empire. It was the outcome of a
political agreement concluded in
Medelum, how do you ever however you say
that modern Milan
between the Roman emperors Constantine 1
and Lysinius
in February 313. The proclamation made
for the east by Linus in June uh 313
granted all persons freedom to worship
whatever deity they pleased, assured
Christians of legal rights, including
the right to organized churches, and
directed the prompt return of Christians
of comp and directed the prompt return
to Christians of confiscated property.
Previous edicts of toleration had been
as short-lived as the regimes that
sanctioned them. But this time the edict
effectively established religious
toleration.
The extent copies of the decree are
those posted by licist in the eastern
parts of the empire. Close quote.
It established religious toleration.
That was the heart of it.
Which is a sheer case of divine irony.
Because one of the other big boogeymen
that the SDA church loves to claim is
that there's a war on this exact thing
and their freedom to worship on Saturday
is under attack.
This is precisely what the edict of
Milan secured for Christians
was legal protection from religious
persecution.
So Constantine enacted a law that
legally recognized Christianity
alongside the pagan religions of the
day. He makes no reference to the ten
commandments, changing the fourth
commandment, worshiping the sun, etc.
because the edict had nothing to do with
that. The two groups, pagans and
Christians, weren't even united. The
pagan Romans didn't have weekly
festivals. Their festivals were annual
like a holiday.
But the Christian day was weekly, every
Sunday. And like Shaw said, Constantine
made these synchronize by giving the
preference to Sunday, the Christian day.
It was a civil action on his part. And
the civil law required pagans to respect
the day Christians were worshiping. The
point being, it had nothing to do with
intermingling sun worship with pagans
into Christianity.
As for him citing Arthur Wel, Doug,
Arthur Wigle was an Egyptologist,
not a church historian or theologian,
and he was wrong. The Jehovah's
Witnesses Watchtower also cites that
same guy. Just Google him.
The Jehovah's Witnesses Watchtower also
cite that same guy in some of their
materials to try and support the
rejection of the Trinity as being pagan
because he's an Egyptologist.
So nice try, but no, he was wrong. It
had nothing to do with taking over pagan
festivals to give them to uh Christian
significance. He mentioned the church
fathers. My the irony. Doug, you have
zero business citing the church fathers
on this subject. Not a single one of
them. Oh, the church fathers were all
saying that it just was
No, dude. If you'd read the Church
Fathers like you'd read any of these
other sources, no, you wouldn't be
saying what you're saying tonight. You'd
have a a different critique
because they all understood the Sabbath.
They weren't in ignorance.
And I know you guys love to claim
because Ellen White did that everyone
before the light on the Sabbath truth
was revealed, they were resting in peace
because they didn't have the light. No,
you're wrong. They all understood the
Jewish Sabbath. Yes, that's what it is.
the old creation Sabbath and they
rejected it because Jesus inaugurated
the new creation.
And as we saw in part one, no,
Christians didn't eventually reject what
the SDA church calls the Bible Sabbath.
They love to attach the word Bible
Christians to the the front the the
front of things
to make it appear and sound like it's
just, oh, it's just the the biblical
teaching and they just believe what the
Bible does and no one else does. But no,
early Christians did not adopt Sunday
because it was a feast day over and
against Saturday being a fast day and
they liked feasting more than they did
fasting.
Like what a spin. What a spin. Yeah,
they had all sorts of fast days, Doug.
It wasn't just It's just again these
sorts of breezing driveby
sort of smatterings and claims. It's
just like you get the shotgun gish
gallop of so much stuff and then you
think, "Oh, well, he cited a ton of the
Bible. Oh, wow. He cited these
historical sources. Dude, you have no
clue what you're talking about. This has
been one long chain of historical
revisionism, misrepresentation, and
fiction.
The church fathers like I'm still
thinking about this. The church fathers
do not agree with you that this
development happened. Like you said,
you like you grazed over a number of
details that some of the fathers
highlight, like Saturday being a fast
day, but then you weave into that your
fictional narrative that you're spinning
to make it look like they agree with you
when they don't.
And then you bore false witness yet
again, claiming it's man-made tradition
that has nothing to do with the
teachings of God. This coming from the
guy that doesn't even understand what
he's criticizing.
Still waiting for that mention, just a
mention of it of new creation.
Yet you're going to try and cite the
church fathers. The irony. Here's some
quotes just from church history. This is
the Catholic encyclopedia volume 4. The
church after changing the day of rest
from the Jewish Sabbath or the seventh
day of the week to the first made the
third commandment refer to Sunday as the
day to be kept holy as the Lord's day.
Now, I took this picture. This is a
picture, a granite copy of the Ten
Commandments in front of a Catholic
church here in Sacramento. If you look
real close, you'll see a picture of me
in my t-shirt taking a picture
reflected.
This is and and I I zoomed in a little
bit. I want you to notice something
here. They don't have the second
commandment. The second commandment they
make, don't take the name of the Lord
your vain. That's supposed to be the
third commandment. They delete the
commandment about idolatry. It's totally
not there. They take the fourth
commandment and they make it the third
commandment.
And then in order to keep ten
commandments, they then take the 10th
commandment and they divide it. They
instead of thou shalt not covet, they
say don't covet your neighbor's wife and
don't coveret your neighbor's house. And
they should make 13 commandments. Don't
cover your neighbor's donkey, too. They
should have made a third one out of
that. But they tried to maintain the
number 10. Says the beast power would
think to change times and laws, and they
certainly did that.
Wow.
All right, folks. Buckle up.
So, now it's because of Romanism.
First, it was Gentiles taking over, not
liking Jews, but they wanted to
evangelize more easily, so they adopted
pagan practices. Then it was
Constantine's edict of Milan. Now it's
because of Roman Catholicism and the
Pope supposedly. Doug, you are a
dishonest person. Did you notice what
was cut off, folks,
from the picture,
the first commandment?
Let's bring this back a titch. Look at
the photo. Look what's at the top of top
left. Second commandment.
Huh. I wonder why Doug cut the first
commandment off
first. When the Roman church Doug says
the church changed the Sabbath, they
mean the apostles.
They think the apostles were the first
Roman Catholics.
And they mean that Jesus instituted the
first day with the disciples. And the
apostles continued this practice,
handing it down to us.
This is what the likes of Ignatius and
others were talking about regarding new
creation that you have yet to even
mention. The arguments that Protestants
have or have had and still have with
Rome over the subject are in the vein of
apostolic succession and what it means
to go back to the apostles because both
sides agree this practice worship on the
first day is apostolic in nature by
virtue of Jesus beginning it with his
apostles.
We agree with Rome on how or we disagree
with Rome on how Protestants are
connected back to the apostles. But the
point being, you cite the Catholic
Encyclopedia as if it helps your case or
proves your point. It doesn't. You guys
read into these quotes like you just did
to try and support that the papacy
hundreds of years after the apostles
changed the Sabbath like Daniel
predicted and so on. reading all of your
great controversy narrative into the
quote when that's not what at all is
being said. Now, Doug, I have this
Catholic encyclopedia.
So, I referenced it when I saw you cite
it. What I found was that you or your
assistant, whoever made this
presentation, did a quote mine and
didn't look at where you were citing
from, or you wouldn't have gone on to
say what you did regarding the removal
of the commandments. Either that or,
like I said, you're a dishonest person.
which I'm beginning to think you are
based on the way you snap that photo.
Because folks, you know what the New
Catholic Encyclopedia Volume 4 says in
the literal next sentence of what he
cited? Notice what sentence he omitted.
So he read everything that's not
highlighted.
The church on the other hand after
changing the day of rest from the Jewish
Sabbath or seventh day of the week to
the first made the third commandment
refer to Sunday as the day to be kept
holy as the Lord's day. This is the
sentence. The Council of Trent with the
reference there condemns those who deny
that the Ten Commandments are binding on
Christians.
Hold up, hold up, hold up, hold up. Does
it say eight?
Does it say nine?
No, all 10.
This is in the section of the
encyclopedia talking about the ten
commandments. Why' you leave out that
last sentence, Doug?
Oh, no, no, no. See, it's the ten
commandments of of the two they removed
and then they broke up the other ones to
make it 10. It's only talking about
those. Well, Doug, it gets worse for you
because look what's on the very next
page from the quote that you cited. the
next paragraph, literally the next
paragraph.
Quote, "There is no numerical division
of the commandments in the books of
Moses, but the injunctions are
distinctly 10-fold and are found almost
identical in both sources. The order too
is the same except for the final
prohibitions pronounced against uh
concupisence.
That of Deuteronomy being adopted in
preference to Exodus. A confusion
however exists in the numbering which is
due to a difference of opinion
concerning the initial precept on divine
worship. The system of numeration found
in Catholic Bibles is based on the
Hebrew text
and was made by St. Augustine in the
fifth century in his book of questions
on e of of Exodus
and and was adopted by the council of
Trent. It is followed also by the German
Lutheran except those of the school of
the school of Martin Buucer.
This arrangement makes the first
commandment relate to false worship and
the worship of false gods as to a single
subject in a single class of sins to be
guarded against the reference to idols
being regarded as mere application of
the precept to adore but one God and the
prohibition as directed against the
particular offense of idolatry alone.
According
to this manner of reckoning, the
injunction forbidding the use of the
Lord's name in vain comes second in
order and the decimal number is
safeguarded by making a division of the
final precept on concupisence. The ninth
pointing to sins of the flesh and the
10th to the desire for unlawful
possession of goods. Close quote. Ah, so
the Roman Catholic Church teaches the
binding validity of the ten
commandments, all 10 of them. And the
reason they enjoin the first and second
and spread out the tenth is due to the
Hebrew text not having numeric division.
But all 10 are there.
Yes, including the second.
It's enjoined to the first commandment.
Doug, this is called the Augustinian
order. Nothing nefarious.
I guess you guys love to appeal to
Luther and his angst for the papacy like
Walter Vice was doing a couple weeks
ago. I guess Lutheran are now the beast
power that changed times and laws too
because they used the Augustinian order
also.
The text does not give an inspired
numbering which is why there have been
various number numberings throughout
history because there's actually 13
imperatives not only 10.
and to speak on this and to show that
this has been a long-standing
understanding.
Notice what Origin says in his homalies
in Exodus
3rd century. Quote, the first
commandment therefore is you shall not
have other gods beside me. And after
this follows, you shall not make for
yourself an idol or any likeness of
anything which is in heaven above or in
the earth beneath or in the waters under
the earth. You shall neither adore nor
worship them. For I am the Lord your
God, a jealous God who avenges the sins
of the fathers on the sons of the third
and fourth generation for those who hate
me and show mercy to thousands for those
who love me and who keep my
commandments.
Some think that all these words together
are one commandment.
But if it be thus supposed, the number
10 of the commandments will not be
completed and where now will be the
truth of the decalogue.
But if it be divided in that manner in
which we also separated it in the
preceding reading, the whole number of
ten commandments will appear. The first
commandment therefore is you shall not
have other gods beside me. The second is
you shall not make for yourself an idol
nor any uh nor any likeness etc. close
quote.
So origin explains there are some that
believe the words of what we call the
second commandment are in join to what
we call the first. This is way back in
the 3rd century and it has to do with
the Hebrew language. But regardless of
the numbering, the substance of both is
still present in Rome's teaching and
Bible translation. So Doug is
misinformed on this and is more than
likely just regurgitating what he's
heard repeated in SDA circles,
especially considering that in the
literal next paragraph of the book you
cited from the next sentence
in the quote that you gave,
they state that they not only believe
all 10 are binding, but also the reasons
for enjoining the first and second and
distinguishing the 10th, which is
evidence you didn't actually get this
quote from the book yourself.
You got it from one of these seventh day
propaganda sites.
And yes, I'm aware that many Puritans
also made this claim that Doug did. And
guess what? They were wrong. And I like
many of them. I just cited Thomas Watson
a few weeks ago, his book, The Ten
Commandments. And he makes this claim in
there. And I don't know what access to
information he had in his day, but
nevertheless, he was wrong.
The Roman church still affirms the
second commandment. You might disagree
with their interpretation and
application of it. I know I do.
But that isn't the same as saying that
they have removed it to allow for
idolatry. And this is evidence that
Daniel was prophesying about the papacy
who would change the ten commandments.
Very deceptive and dishonest, sir. And
as for the 10th commandment,
uh yeah, Doug, because coveting your
neighbor's wife is not the same as
coveting your neighbor's donkey.
A wife is not a possession.
There's a distinction there. That's all
that's going on. That's why they make
the distinction. Lutheran do the same.
And a catechism is a teaching tool.
They're seeking to teach children that a
human is not a possession.
It's really not that complicated.
But yet again, this guy has no clue what
he is criticizing. And you don't have to
be a Roman Catholic to understand this
and represent people accurately.
And it's sad that saying such is going
to lead to SDA's call, which what else
is new? Is going to lead to them calling
me a Roman Catholic, a merry worshiper.
whatever. We know some of us actually do
care about the other commandments,
namely the ninth, and we're sick of
hearing you guys rally cry that you're
the commandment keepers,
while you misrepresent and slander and
lie about other people.
Furthermore, here's the Catholic
Church's Bible translation, the DAS of
Exodus 20 2-5.
I am the Lord thy God, who brought thee
out of the land of Egypt, out of the
house of bondage. Thou shalt not have
strange gods before me. Thou shalt not
make make to thyself a graven image, nor
the likeness of anything that is in
heaven above, or in the earth beneath,
nor of those things that are in the
waters under the earth. Thou shalt not
adore them, nor serve them. I am the
Lord thy God, mighty, jealous, visiting
the iniquity of the fathers upon the
children, upon the third and fourth
generation of them that hate me.
So they supposedly removed it from their
catechism but included in their Bible
translation. Yeah, it makes total sense.
This is bad argumentation, folks. Do not
use these arguments, please, when
engaging with Roman Catholics.
It will set up any seasoned Roman
Catholic apologist to jump off the top
rope and flying elbow that level of
apologetic through the ring and bury it.
Adventist, when you say this, Roman
Catholics immediately are going to
dismiss anything else that you have to
say because they're going to know you
didn't even bother to learn what they
actually believe. It would be the
equivalent of when someone says, "Ellen
White originated all of SDA teaching."
Adventists will immediately just dismiss
anything else someone has to say because
they know she didn't originate any of
the teaching, but supposedly received
vision confirming the beliefs that they
say were arrived at through deep
biblical study. That's the belief and
claim.
Or it' be the same as when people try to
come against Esus, you believe Jesus is
an angel because you think he's Michael
the Archangel. When they're going to
say, "No, we believe Michael is an
uncreated, not angelic being, but a
title of of Christ."
So, it' be the same thing as when
somebody shouts that out and you guys
just immediately shut down and say,
"Well, you don't even know what you're
criticizing. I'm going to ignore
everything else you say." That's what
Roman Catholics are going to do when you
say this level of nonsense because
that's what it is. So the point being,
don't use this silly argument that Roman
that that Rome removed some of the ten
commandments. Just please don't do that.
And they should make 13 commandments.
Don't cover your neighbor's donkey, too.
They should have made a third one out of
that. But they tried to maintain the
number 10. Says the beast power would
think to change times and laws. And they
certainly did that. What do Sunday
churches say about this problem? Now
friends, stay with me. I'm going to do
some reading here.
I I'm going to just read quotes from
other churches scholars official
statements so you know they know that
something is wrong. Baptist from the
Baptist manual. There is no scriptural
evidence of the change of the Sabbath
institution from the seventh to the
first day of the week. That's pretty
clear. Amen. No scriptural evidence.
Another Baptist commentary. This is
called the Lord's day in our day by
William Owen Carver.
There was never any formal or
authoritative change from the Jewish
seventh day Sabbath to the Christian
first day observance. It's not there. Uh
Alexander Campbell, one of the leaders
in the Church of Christ, I do not
believe the Lord's day was changed from
the seventh day to the first day.
Catholic, this is from the book Cardinal
James Gibbons, Faith of Our Fathers. You
may read the Bible from Genesis to
Revelation. You'll not find a single
line authorizing the sanctification of
Sunday. The Catholic Church for over a
thousand years before the existence of a
Protestant by virtue of her own divine
mission changed the day from Saturday to
Sunday. They freely admit that they were
there. The holy uh the holy day, the
Sabbath was changed from Saturday to
Sunday, the day of the Lord, not based
on scriptural authority, but from the
church's sense of its own power. Catch
the rest of this. People who think the
scripture should be their sole authority
should logically become Seventh Day
Adventist and keep Saturday holy. Amen.
Well, they admit it. I appreciate that.
Catholic services appeal 1995 from uh
Cath St. Katherine Catholic Church, St.
Clair Boulevard. Uh you got one from the
Anglican Church. And where are we told
in the scriptures that we're to keep the
first day at all? We're commanded to
keep the seventh day, but we are nowhere
commanded to keep the first day. The
reason why we keep the first day of the
week holy instead of the seventh is
because the church has enjoined it. They
say it's something that church fathers
did. But they have no right to change
the law of God. Is did God say, "I'll
bless whatever day you pick." Or did he
say, "You keep my day." And he told us
what his day is. It's the Sabbath of the
Lord.
Is there any command Episcopal writers
any command in the New Testament to
change the day of the week of rest from
Saturday to Sunday? None. That's their
manual of Christian doctrine. Methodists
Harris Franklin R. He's a Methodist
theologian. Take the matter of Sunday.
There is no passage telling Christians
to keep the day.
Doug, you are literally just paring
quotes from this site.
One second, folks.
Simply citing individuals like this as
though it's a universal agreed upon
thing is ridiculous. Look at this folks.
You can find all the ones that he that
he cited from here. The generic Baptist
Church manual. There's William Owen
Carvers,
the Lord's Day and our day.
You can go to all the ones. He went to
Church of Christ that's under here. You
can go to Catholic. They love all these
same ones that they just parrot and
recycle.
You've been talking for almost 45
minutes at this point and you haven't
even one time mentioned the new
creation.
You didn't cite Hebrews 4 1-11. You
completely missed why Acts 20:7, Matthew
28:1, etc. are even cited. You just
breezed over them asking an irrelevant
question of where do these verses give
us a new commandment when that isn't why
they're cited. There's supplemental
support for the fact that the church was
doing the substance of everything we do
today on the first day. Now you parrot a
bunch of quotes SDAs regularly circulate
and all parrot. And based on your track
record thus far with SHA, the Catholic
Encyclopedia, etc. I'm going to go out
on a limb here and say you or your
assistant didn't read any of these
sources either. You simply grab from the
bag of quotes that you've latched on to
for decade for decades and recycle. For
example,
just go and type in William Owen Carver,
the Lord's Day in Our Day, page 49.
And look at how many of the sites I just
showed you pop up, all paring these same
quotes.
And part of the evidence that they
clearly didn't read it for themselves,
all of them,
is the fact that they all left off the
letter S.
They cite the book wrong and then they
all borrow it
because the book title is the Lord's Day
in our days plural.
But again, Christian Adventists love
doing this gish gallop on this topic.
They'll just throw these quote mind
quotes out there and think that it's
just like, haha, see, even Protestants
know there's a problem.
Doug, you said you were citing scholars
to try and make the quotes hit harder.
Wo. Carver was a professor of missions
at Southern Baptist Theological
Seminary.
His Baptist manual is not a Baptist
confession. It was an individual
document he put together. Alexander
Campbell wasn't even a Christian, but a
restorationist that claims the church
completely fell away and he was a part
of restoring it. You cited the Catholic
Mirror, another Catholic source you guys
love to use and abuse, which is talking
about what I mentioned earlier, the
claim to Protestants having no
connection back to the apostles
supposedly. And since the apostles
instituted such practice in the church
by continuing what Jesus started with
them, Protestants then have no basis for
the practice. That's the context of the
discussion. Apostolic succession. It's
not them admitting what you guys claim
about the papacy and Daniel saying that
the pope would change times and laws and
all the other Greek great controversy
junk that you've read into it. Then he
cited their absolute favorite one, the
1995 Catholic services appeal that says
if one holds to the sole authority of
the Bible, they should be an SDA. They
love this quote. As you heard the people
in the crowd,
which is another example of their
cherry-picking.
They like Rome when it favors them.
Otherwise, it's all papal deception and
lies.
He cites an Anglican and demonstrates he
doesn't even know what's being said.
That quote isn't referring to the church
fathers. Doug,
by the church, they mean the apostles.
The apostles, not the church fathers.
And Protestants, which Anglicans are a
part of, and Catholics agree on that?
They argue if Protestants do actually go
back to the apostles, and if so, how?
So then Rome says, "If we don't, we have
no basis for the first day because it
ultimately goes back to Jesus
instituting it with the apostles, not
the church fathers."
What if we did this with SDAs? And that
was our argument. Look at this SDA over
here and over there. They'd get in a
tizzy so fast.
He very obviously went into one of these
or his assistant, whoever, clearly went
into one of these 7th day sabotarian
sites and just mind the quotes without
actually examining the document
themselves
because so far Doug hasn't even engaged
with the argument.
He's just claimed it has no rhyme or
reason and then he's knocked down a
bunch of straw men, citing other people
who who who could have not been aware of
the history or arguments themselves to
then use them as a representative of the
whole, which is a hasty generalization,
not an argument.
What is Apostle Paul saying in Romans
14? I hear people whenever they learn
the Sabbath truth, they say, "Well, wait
a second now, we don't really need to
keep any day." And they go right to two
verses. Romans 14, Colossians 2. We're
going to look at them real quick because
we're not afraid of any of these verses.
Romans 14:5 and 6, Paul says, "One
person esteems one day above another.
Another esteems every day alike. Let
each one be fully convinced in his own
ma in his own uh mind."
So, you want to keep Sunday, you keep
Sunday, I'll keep Saturday. You know,
I've never heard a Sunday pastor stand
up and tell his congregation, you keep
whatever day you want to keep. They
don't ever say, "You want to go Sabbath?
It's fine. Uh they well there might be
some but uh there are actually some
Sunday churches having services on two
days a week now because more of them are
learning that more of their members are
asking questions because they're
watching Amazing Facts programs.
I I know one pastor that told me you're
causing me a lot of problems.
But um this is simply saying they're
talking about the Jewish ceremonial laws
that if you want to keep Passover, the
the Jews that were very scrupulous about
keeping the annual feast, he said,
"Look, if you want to keep that day,
keep it to the Lord, but don't make
other people keep it." I tell Christians
that some people say, "Are we supposed
to celebrate Christmas?" I said, "Look,
if you want to remember the gift of God,
giving a son, that's up to you. Don't
tell someone else they have to. There's
no scripture command about it. If you're
going to do it, don't do it for elves
and Santa Claus. do it for Jesus coming
into the world. So there's, you know,
it's up to you what you want to do.
That's how I would use that. Would God
ever say concerning the Sabbath? I
realized I had a man stoned to death for
breaking the Sabbath in the Old
Testament, but if you want to keep it,
it's up to you.
Is that the same God? No. It's one of
God's commandments. Sin is the
transgression of the law. He who
observes the day observes it to the
Lord. He who does not observe the day to
the Lord, he does not observe it.
So, what is meant in Colossians 2:14-16?
And we're going to look at that real
quick. Let me read it to you. Notice now
you you can look it up in your Bible. I
want you to follow these words carefully
because someone's going to ask you about
this. Having wiped out the handwriting
of ordinances. Notice it's handwriting
of ordinances that was against us.
Notice the word against us which was
contrary to us. And he took it out of
the way, having nailed it to the cross,
having disarmed pr principalities and
powers. He made a public spectacle of
them, triumphing over them in it. Now,
what is he talking about when he says,
"Having abolished the handwriting and
the ordinances." Look in 2 Chronicles
33:8.
That you take heed to do all that I have
commanded them according to the whole
law and the statutes and the ordinances
by the hand of Moses. You got two laws,
friends. You have the ten commandments
and the ordinances given by Moses. Ten
commandments, hand of God. Ordinances,
handwriting of Moses. Notice that
distinction. Paul in Colossians is
talking about the ordinances.
Deuteronomy 4:13. So he declared to you
his covenant that he commanded you to
perform even the ten commandments.
That's clear, right? And he wrote them
on two tables of stone. And
in addition to that, the Lord commanded
me at that time to teach you statutes
and judgments that you might observe
them. Those are the ordinances in the
land that you cross over to possess.
They're written by a man's hand on
paper. 2 Kings 2:18. Only if they are
careful to do all that I have commanded
them and according to all the law that
my servant Moses commanded them. You got
the Ten Commandments and the law of
Moses. two separate distinct laws. God
kept them separate. You got the ark of
the covenant. What's inside the ark?
Ten Commandments. But what about the
ordinances? Take this book of the law,
put it in the side of the ark. It was a
pocket on the outside of the covenant of
the Lord your God that it might be there
as a witness against thee. He says,
blotting out the handwriting of
ordinances that were against us. So
what's nailed to the cross? the ten
commandments or the ceremonial Sabbaths
that you find in the Bible. Colossians
2:16-1 17. Notice, so let no one judge
you in food or drink or regarding a
festival or new moon or Sabbaths small s
plural. Sabbaths. Now he tells you what
kind of Sabbaths. Sabbaths which are a
shadow of things to come, but the
substances of Christ. There were certain
Sabbaths that came after sin. They were
annual feasts that were shadows for
telling the coming of Christ. They were
nailed to the cross. The handwriting of
Moses, not the Sabbath that was part of
creation. Bible says in heaven, we're
going to keep that one. From one Sabbath
to another, all flesh will come and
worship before the Lord. It's the annual
Sabbath that Paul is talking about. And
you know, I just went through for my own
edification last night. I looked up
these verses. I went through all of the
Protestant scholars,
Matthew Henry, Adam Clark, John Gil, um
Jameus's Fossen Brown, Spurgeon, you can
look at them all. They all understand
the Sabbaths that were nailed to the
cross were ceremonial Sabbaths. It's
only recently that theologians are
saying that one of the commandments was
nailed to the cross. None of the
Protestant Puritan fathers believe that.
And so, um it's just a heresy that's
come in.
the irony.
So, Romans 14, notice Paul doesn't state
what you guys do in Romans 14 regarding
anything about the Sabbath being a seal.
Why do I bring this up? Well, if that
were the case, the Sabbath were the
seal, it would be very odd that Paul
would say what he did and not make sure
to clarify that.
I talked about this in my very first
YouTube video as one of the reasons why
I left Adventism. Sabbath seal is a
myth.
They want to talk about just believing
the Bible and utilizing the verbatim
fallacy. How's about where the Bible
verbatim says the Sabbath is the seal,
Doug? Well, wait.
They're going to comment Exodus and
Ezekiel says it was a sign.
You know what verbatim means? But then
Colossians 2. So, we're going to camp
out here for a second.
No, Doug. Colossians 2 doesn't say any
law was nailed to the cross.
You guys rely on the King James
rendering of the phrase handwriting of
ordinances to then try and equate that
with the book of the law in Deuteronomy
31 and elsewhere. We've addressed this
in a video from a number of months ago.
Using Doug Bachelor as the example, the
book of the law contained all of the
first five books of the Bible, the
Pentatuk, which means it contained the
Ten Commandments twice.
You can go look up the video. two laws,
question mark, Moses's law and God's
law.
So, as you heard him say, they say the
Ten Commandments are God's and the rest
was Moses's.
Except,
no, it's all God's. And he used Moses as
a mediator to relay it.
Doug, you think the Israelites breaking
the Ten Commandments didn't stand
against them? Only ceremonial laws.
If you go to Deuteronomy 31 where he
cites at the beginning when when Moses
is talking to Aaron or Joshua, sorry,
and he gives them the book of the law,
the command is to teach your children to
obey all these things. Oh, so the
children weren't taught to obey the ten
commandments.
We go through so many verses. We go
through 2 Chronicles like he did. We go
all over the place. The book of the law
contained the Ten Commandments twice.
The book on the outside of the ark,
Doug, contained the Ten Commandments in
both Exodus and Deuteronomy. It wasn't a
book of just ceremonial functions.
You would know this, Doug, if you didn't
just hopcotch around the Bible and
actually looked at entire passages and
worked through them verse by verse. But
secondly, the Greek word used in
Colossians 2 for handwriting of
ordinances or certificate of debt if you
use a different translation is
kerograph.
It's a legal term
and this is the only place in scripture
that it's used which is why like any hop
lama there's all theologians like the
Lord's day kuryaka heimera like we
looked at last week. There's a lot of of
focus and and time that theologians put
into a hotbox is simply a single usage
of the word in a body of of text. Well,
this is one of them. This is the only
place this word occurs. Doug wants to
try and say by the SDA church because
that's what they say is that it's
talking about the handwriting of Moses
and that's what was nailed. No, it's
not. You did word association fallacy.
See, it says ordinances over here and so
it says handwriting ordinances over
here. It's talking about the Mosaic law
that stood against them. That's what was
done away with. No, it's not talking
about any law being nailed to the cross.
This word is a legal term and it has to
do with debt that a person has incurred.
And Jesus himself equates sin with debt
in the Lord's prayer. If you compare
Matthew and Luke in one he says,
"Forgive us our debts." The other he
says, "Forgive us our sins."
Paul is saying that Jesus paid the debt
that believers had incurred by their sin
which yes was for violating even the
moral law because again it's not in
focus of cancelelling out a a type of
law.
He then Jesus then bore the sin of those
people in his body on the cross and he
was then nailed to it cancelling the
debt by paying it in full
and that is then why he goes on to say
let no one judge you in a festival new
moon sabbaths etc.
It is not talking about ceremonial laws
being nailed to the cross but ultimately
fulfilled in the person and work of
Christ the substance.
I mean think about it. So God disarmed
rulers and principalities. Colossians 2,
that's what it goes on to say. God
apparently disarmed rulers and
principalities by nailing Israel
Israelite ceremonial laws to the cross.
Doesn't even make sense in the flow of
what Paul is saying.
He's talking about Jesus who is the
substance of the shadow of things to
come. G kind of like we've been talking
about last week and this week. And he
removed the barrier between man and God
by paying the debt they owed in full
reconciling them to God. like he says in
Romans 5
because this set of verses is actually
said in the context if you start back in
chapter 1 2 of union with Christ where
in verse 11 he mentions that those who
are in him that phrase I constantly
point to have been inwardly circumcised
by virtue of being in Christ. And so he
says to not let anyone take you captive
by empty philosophy and deceit which
many people proof text to apply to any
sort of philosophy. But he's actually
talking about Judaizers
who seek to bind people to old
typological shadows and customs like the
SDA church.
And for believers to not let these
individuals deceive you because by
virtue of being in Christ, you as a
believer already have the substance of
those types and shadows such as
circumcision, the feast days. etc.
Furthermore, you guys put yourself in a
pickle when you claim this by talking
about ceremonial laws being nailed to
the cross because Doug, the day of
atonement was a part of ceremonial law,
as is seen in the same chapter you just
had up on the screen, Leviticus 23. And
yet you guys think the day of atonement
began 1,800 some odd years after the
cross, and it wasn't nailed to it, even
though it was a part of ceremonial law.
Also, all ceremonial law was not nailed
to the cross because baptism, the Lord's
supper, gathering for corporate worship,
etc., those are all ceremonial laws.
Laws being they are commanded and they
are ceremonial in nature.
But this is specifically referring to
believers not being taken captive and
led astray by Jewish ordinances that
were a type and shadow because we
already have the substance which is
Christ. But then Leviticus 23 and annual
Sabbath. Doug, you just said earlier
there was no evidence of the first day
being anything other than a normal
working day. Yet, you cite Leviticus 23,
which talks about the first day,
regardless of what day it fell on,
was to be a holy convocation with no
ordinary work to be done on it.
Yet, you didn't bring any of those up on
your your slide. You only looked at the
feast of trumpets, which we saw that one
last week when we looked at the the
sample calendar when it fell on the the
first day, etc. This would move around
based on the Jewish calendar. The point
being, it was the pattern, not some sort
of ontological divinity that a 24-hour
rotation around the sun has. But Doug,
it's funny you mention Matthew Henry,
Adam Clark, John Gil, Spurgeon to say
they all agreed, this is referring to
festival Sabbaths, they all agreed on
the binding validity of the weekly
Sabbath. Yes. And they all fundamentally
disagreed with you on virtually every
aspect of what that means
because they all understood new
creation, something you still have yet
to mention. So he cited Methodist
theologian Adam Clark, who I know Doug
loves because I've heard him cite Clark
a number of times. And SDA's love to
say, "We're firmly in the Methodist
tradition." Well, what does Clark mean
by the Sabbath being a perpetually
binding ordinance, Doug?
You say this as if all the commenters
that you said support your guy's
position. Notice
Adam Clark commentary on Colossians
21:16.
Quote, "There is no intimation here that
the Sabbath was done away or that its
moral use was superseded by the
introduction of Christianity. I have
shown elsewhere that remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy is a command
of perpetual obligation and can never be
superseded but by the final termination
of time.
As it is a type of that rest which
remains for the people of God of an
eternity of bliss, it must continue in
full force till that eternity arrives.
For no type ever ceases till the
antitype become. Besides, it is not
clear that the apostles refer to all of
the Sabbath in this place, whether
Jewish or Christian.
His of Sabbaths, and that's the Greek
for the phrase of Sabbaths there, or
weeks most probably refers to their
feast of weeks, of which much has been
said in the notes on the penetuk. Close
quote.
So for all the SDAs that like to appeal
to their church being staunchly in the
Methodist tradition, there you go. One
of the foremost Methodist theologians.
And what does he recognize?
There was a Jewish Sabbath and a
Christian Sabbath.
exactly what I've been saying and
Christians have been saying for nearly
2,000 years,
which Doug actually disregarded earlier
on in this presentation by saying
Christians later started calling it the
seventh day or started calling the
seventh day the Jewish Sabbath out of
spite for Jews. But two, Clark rightly
recognizes that the Christian Sabbath is
a type of the ultimate rest which
remains for the people of God in
eternity and the Christian Sabbath will
be in full force until when?
until we enter eternity. Not that in
eternity there will be days with moon
and sun cycles such that that that time
will be like it is kept now.
Doug tried weasling that in citing
Isaiah 66:23 like they always do to say
see the 7th day Sabbath will continue
into eternity even though it says from
new moon to new moon and they don't keep
the new moons
and revelation says there will be no
moon in eternity
which is the evidence that something
else is going on in Isaiah that they
miss but Clark rightly recognizes that
the Christian Sabbath just like the the
Jewish Sabbath
both were typological of the eternal
rest of heaven. Not that the Christian
or Jewish Sabbath will be observed every
seven days in eternity. He's he's
essentially reiterating what we've shown
on this platform multiple times from
Hebrews. Hebrews 4 1-11. Same thing John
Owen was saying. Same thing you you'll
find Spurgeon saying who he mentioned.
Same thing you'll find countless
commentators stating. He cited John Gil.
Doug John Gil was a reformed Baptist
affirming the 1689 London Baptist
Confession. It is the cousin confession
of the Westminster Confession of Faith,
which is what I hold too, and is 95%
identical to it. He affirmed the
Christian Sabbath. Notice what he says
in his Colossians commentary.
quote speaking of the phrase or of the
Sabbath days or Sabbaths meaning the
Jubilee Sabbath which was 1 year and 50
and the Sabbath of the land which was 1
year and seven and the seventh day
Sabbath
and some copies read in the the singular
number or of the Sabbath. Doug likes to
always mention that too. Oh, it says
Sabbaths plural. That means it always
has to be referring to No, not
necessarily. It's a lot more complicated
than that, dude.
I'm going to skip back here because
notice what he's saying. I know that
there's a lot of semicolons and stuff
here,
but he says speaking of the phrase of
the uh uh of the Sabbath days or
Sabbaths, meaning the Jubilee Sabbath,
the Sabbath of the land, and the seventh
day Sabbath, and some copies of
manuscripts read in the singular number
or of the Sabbath, which were all
peculiar to the Jews,
were never binding on the Gentiles,
and to which believers in Christ be they
who they will are by no means obligated
nor ought they to observe them.
The one any more than the other, and
they should be imposed upon them, they
ought to reject them.
And should they be judged, censured, and
and condemned for doing so, they ought
not to mind it.
Whoops.
He goes on in his commentary,
but you get the point. Gil didn't agree
that the Jewish Sabbath aspect was
included in what was removed at Calvary
Doug.
Does that sound like someone that agrees
with the SDA church's position? Not at
all.
Yes, Gil believed the substance of the
fourth commandment to be perpetually
binding, which is what the command is
actually about. The day is a part of the
form, the ceremonial form of the
command, and the form can change.
Yet, the substance of the command is
still the same. God is due a portion of
his image bears time to step away from
taking dominion and subduing the earth,
i.e. working, to focus on him, worship
him, give thanks, rest, and recover,
etc.
I know I say it a lot, but the SDA
church in infuses this sort of like
divine characteristic into Saturday,
making the day itself, the substance of
the command, as though days are eternal
when no, they're a part of creation,
which shows they worship creation, not
us. They've elevated a part of creation
to a divine status.
Doug just got done claiming earlier that
early Christians erroneously ascribed a
distinction between the Christian and
Jewish Sabbath. Yet Adam Clark, a
Methodist, and John Gil, a reformed
Baptist, both recognized that same
distinction as well.
Gil recognized that the fourth
commandment was still binding, but not
the same ceremonial form in the
Christian era, meaning the seventh day.
That was Jewish.
None of the people that Doug cited
agree with the SDA church's Judaizing,
making the Sabbath a seal, that
Saturdays will be observed in heaven
like they do now, and all the other
great controversy details they claim,
you know, about the Sabbath. So don't
try and cite them to ride their
coattails to bolster your guys'
twisting. The only general aspect they
would agree with you on is that the
fourth commandment is still binding, but
not in the way you guys claim and not
for the same reasons.
They all agreed with the Christian
Sabbath position that I'm putting forth,
not the Jewish position that you're
putting forth, which isn't even really
the Jewish position. It's your own
tradition.
Does Revelation say God's people will be
keeping his commandments in the last
days? Why am I preaching this? Because
before Jesus comes, there's got to be a
revival. Three angels message is calling
people to return to the creator. Right?
Worship him who made. That means if
you're going to remember the creator,
remember the day he set aside for that.
Revelation 12:17, the dragon was wroth
with the woman and went to make war with
the remnant of her seed that keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus. Blessed are they
that do his commandments that they might
have a right to the tree of God and they
may enter in through the gates of the
city. And again, it says Hebrews 5:9,
"And being made perfect, he became the
eternal author, the author of eternal
salvation unto all them that obey him."
You know, all over North America,
there's train tracks. We have train
tracks. You ever heard the train go by
while we're doing the service right
here? Train tracks right out there. You
know how wide they are? They are 4 feet
8 and a half inches.
All across North America, they've got to
have train tracks the same size or the
trains don't fit the tracks. Do you know
why they're four feet eight and a half
inches? Because when we made our trains
in America, they use the same jigs and
machinery they use for the wagons.
So why are the wagons in America why
were they axle length 4 feet 8 and 1/2
in? Because when the people came over
from England, that was the size of their
wagons. They used the same machinery,
the same measurements that were on their
wagons. Some of them were shipped over
and so they all made them the same
length. Why were all of the wagons in
England that length? Because all of the
wagons in Europe were that length. Why
were all of the wagons in Europe 4 feet
8 and 12 in? because they found if they
did not make them 4' 8 and 1/2 in long,
the wheels did not fit in the stone ruts
on the main roads in Europe and it would
break them off because they were always
fighting the ruts in the road and it
broke off the wheels. So, they had to
make them 4' 8 and 1/2 in. It's really a
bad length for a train. You would like
to have wider wheels on a train. They
wouldn't tip over near as often. Going
around a turn too fast, didn't we just
lose a train? You heard about it in uh
England or no, in uh Washington.
Why were the ruts that size?
Because the Romans built the roads and
the Roman chariots were 4 feet 8 and 1/2
in. The chariot wheels.
Do you know why the Roman chariot wheels
were that wide?
Because that's how wide they needed to
be to accommodate the rear end of two
chariot horses.
So, the trains all over North America
have been governed by the rear end
of two horses.
It's interesting how you get stuck in
something, it's hard to change, but if
you should try to change them now, you
realize you go to China and Japan, their
bullet trains. You know why they're
ahead of us on bullet trains? Cuz they
don't follow the Roman chariot size. and
they were able to get to it faster than
us. So, so God wants us to continue
obeying. Jesus said, Matthew 7:21, "Not
everyone that says unto me, Lord, Lord,"
will enter into the kingdom of heaven,
but he that does the will. So, it's one
thing to say, "Oh, I know that. That's
very interesting, Pastor Doug." But are
you going to be a hearer of the word or
a doer of the word? What is the will of
God? I delight to do your will, oh my
God. Your law is within my heart. When
the law of God, love for your neighbor,
first four commandments is love for God.
Last six commandments are love for your
fellow man. The law is summed up in
love. And if we love him, Jesus said,
why do you call me Lord, Lord, and do
not the things I say? He said, if you
love me, do what? Keep my commandments.
He doesn't want us to just be hearers of
the word. He invites us, "Come unto me
all you who are weary and heavy laden,
and I will give you rest."
So, we got more of the classic hopscotch
exesus fine verses that use the word
commandment or talk about obedience and
just hitch the SDA wagon to it, like
John 14:15, which we just addressed on
Monday, last Monday,
which if you saw or you've studied that
priy, you know that the ten commandments
aren't in focus. And recognizing such
doesn't mean you're dis you're you're it
doesn't say anything what a person
believes about the ten commandments.
That's irrelevant to the fact that
that's not what's in focus there. It is
an insight into this faulty hermeneutic
method that they utilize. But the irony
of him citing this
while he has a false image and depiction
of what's supposed to be Jesus on the
screen while he says it.
But just as long as you don't bow down
to those like the pagan Roman Catholics,
right, Doug?
If you're a former Adventist, I
encourage you one of the my biggest
piece of it pieces of advice, well,
besides finding a sound, solid
bibleelving local church and and being
accountable,
not this idea of being like a rogue
Christian, but outside of that, learn to
get past the spiritual milk style of
interpretation that the SDA church uses
and often times leaves people with
where you just sight Write a verse as if
it supports you by virtue of just citing
it or thinking that everything taught in
scriptures just done so by these little
single proof texts
where you just ramble on and on and on
and on and make a bunch of assertions
and then inserted text here or there.
This is why Paul talks about spiritual
milk and spiritual meat. Not all
doctrine is spiritual meat or or milk.
I guess both.
But at the beginning of this
presentation, he talked about the story
of of the Trojan horse. We didn't look
at that portion because it's just five
minutes of him basically doing the same
thing using these stories, which he's
going to go on another one here in a
moment, just like he did with the guard.
And he always uses them to to like
piously but but look like the humble
Christian guy, misrepresent and slander
Christians because that's what he did
there.
He goes on about tracks and he always
inserts these amazing facts and like ho
and just the you know and really it's
it's but that's what Christians are
doing. It's just cuz see they're just
following this tradition. They don't
really know what they're they're
actually believing. That's what's going
on. Rambles for five minutes claims
Sunday was a Trojan horse weasled into
the church. That's what he says in the
first five minutes. But Doug, you guys
are the king of tro Trojan horsing stuff
in the scripture. Like you just did.
You guys will cite a verse that uses the
word judgment and try and cram in 1844
investigative judgment exclusively for
professing believers and so on.
And there's always this underlying jab
that SDAs are the ones obeying Christ
and everyone else isn't
which assumes their understanding of the
fourth commandment is correct. No, we
don't concede that. I don't concede
that. Nor did the majority of Christians
in Christian history. You claim
Christians are in disobedience to God by
going to church on Sunday. We aren't.
There's always the undertone, too, that
Christians are against obedience. That
SDAs are just about obedience and
everyone else is theological anarchist
with a wild, wild west understanding of
Christianity.
Yet, no, we're against your unlawful
wielding of the law and your
prophetess's claim that obedience
maintains
retains a person's righteous standing
before God as if obedience can be added
to the perfect work of Jesus Christ.
He just assumes their position on
Revelation, which if that's wrong, the
whole thing collapses,
assuming that Revelation 17 and 22 are
about some special end times remnant
group completely cutting off the vast
majority of Christian history,
let alone the original audience John
penned the Revelation to.
But we also get insight into how in the
SDA mind, there is no concept of the law
gospel distinction.
Doug thinks obedience to the law is what
is going to open the gates of heaven to
someone.
Yet they have no concept that the law
requires absolute perfection. You're
already disqualified.
Not breaking it who knows how many times
he has and then confessing it to Jesus
to then have a clean slate again on a
gradual path.
Nope. Doesn't work that way. Doug, you
have to have a perfect righteousness,
having never violated the law a single
time. And that's not given to you in
small spurts by Jesus.
As if it's like a drip feed. And as long
as you you remain doing your part, the
drip feed will essentially get you
there.
You need something imputed to you in
full
such that when a person stands before
God, they're seen as though they lived
the life Christ did and measured up to
the standard even though they didn't.
In their system, you could have small
bits of Jesus's righteousness imparted,
not imputed, to you. But it wouldn't be
enough because you didn't arrive at the
final status needed, which is total
perfection.
You don't get numerous doovers because
of Jesus's help.
Doug bore false witness in this
presentation multiple times violating
the ninth commandment,
which scripture says if you violate one,
you violated the whole thing. You are
deceiving yourself if you think that
going to church on Saturday is going to
cut it. He cited Matthew 7 and the false
teachers and prophets that Jesus turns
away. Sir, that will be countless SDAs
who say, "But but I kept the Sabbath. I
was a part of the remnant church. I had
the three angels messages. I followed
the health message. I gave tithe." And
so on.
You guys are not the commandment keeping
church. You guys worship an idol, a
false god,
the heavenly trio, which isn't even
actually real.
Three gods that are one in a mission and
purpose with the father alone being the
almighty. It's like a tritheistic
monarchian hybrid concept.
You guys make images of what you believe
to be a person of the godhead
violating the second commandment like
you just did
but like these at your own universities.
This is from Walaw Wala University
Church and campus.
The one on the left, front and center on
stage, you have an image of Christ that
all wor that that everyone worships in
front of. Oh no, but we're not bowing
down.
Yeah. Okay. That a statue on campus of
Jesus among us.
You guys violate the second commandment
constantly. And you know what the
response is going to be? That isn't what
the second commandment is teaching. Ah,
so you disagree with some person's
interpretation of one of the
commandments. Isn't that rich?
What if we just said, "Nope, you hate
God's law. You just don't believe the
Bible."
We have an inspired interpretation. So,
if you disagree, you just you hate God's
law.
That's what Adventists do when you
disagree with their false understanding
of the fourth commandment.
You platform and bind the consciences of
millions of people to submit to a woman
who bore the name of God falsely
countless times. She claimed to be
speaking on behalf of God and wasn't
demonstrabably so. You guys don't keep
the Sabbath, the substance of which is
entering into Jesus Christ by faith in
the gospel.
The the Memorial Day means nothing if
you haven't done that. It doesn't mean a
dang thing.
It doesn't mean you guys keep the
Sabbath just because you go to church on
a certain day. You first have to enter
into Christ by faith, the true Christ by
believing the true gospel, not the
Adventist Christ and the cursed
Adventist gospel. You guys are just like
the wilderness wanderers that the author
of Hebrews is warning about.
They were doing the external commands.
They were keeping a day. They didn't
enter.
They perished. They died.
You guys don't keep the sixth
commandment.
And when I say you guys, I'm talking
about the corporate
organization here. You're talking about
the commandment keeping church.
You don't keep the sixth commandment.
Your movement sanctions the murder of
unborn children as one of the leading
providers in your own state of
California, Doug.
And your your movement makes all sorts
of profit off of such practice. You guys
violate the Ninth Commandment
constantly, as you yourself demonstrated
in this presentation multiple times.
It's hardcoded into your guys' beliefs,
as you demonstrated by pariting many of
your pioneers false claims about others
such as Protestants and Roman Catholics.
You guys are kidding yourselves if you
think you are a bastion of
commandmentkeeping.
No, what you mean is you go to church on
Saturday, so you think you're the apple
of God's eye when you're not. He hates
false gospels, which is why he says
anyone spreading one is under his curse
and is damned.
I admire many SDA zeal to seek to obey
God. I really do. Despite what they may
claim about me, I don't take umbrage
with every single jot and tit of
Adventism. But the cart is before the
horse on this one.
I don't know. Maybe the cart is 4 foot 8
in or whatever. Maybe that's the
problem.
But either way, you guys think trying
your best is going to somehow supplement
what Jesus accomplished such that your
obedience and faith put you in God's
good graces. Adventists will argue this
tooth and nail. Whatever. People can
check the sources for themselves. You
conclude.
Their inspired prophetist clearly claims
you maintain your righteous standing
before God, which is what they define
justification as by your obedience.
Okay.
No. No. But it's not obedience to the
gospel like Paul mentions in 1
Thessalonians or the author of Hebrews
mentions in Hebrews 4.
No, no, no.
Again, they do not understand the law
gospel distinction. They do not
understand the proper use of the law.
Adding a fourth use, again, former
Adventist, you're going to know that
they they try and do well, there's a a
tripartite division between moral,
ceremonial, and civil. And then there's
also three uses, folks. They got that
from other people. They didn't originate
that and they twist it because then they
add on a fourth use of the law which is
what completely botches the whole thing
that single addition.
Obedience does not maintain a person's
standing before God. It is the fruit of
being in Christ where a person is
accepted, adopted, forgiven, redeemed,
justified, holy, blameless, and
everything else scripture has to say
about those who are in union with
Christ. Their seeking to obey is a
result of already having all of that.
and they recognize that even on their
best day, we still don't measure up.
That our obedience cannot be tacked on
to what Jesus accomplished already. And
it's strictly and solely by him and his
perfect work that we are kept secure and
seen as righteous before God.
So, no, Doug, we're not against the law.
were against your guys' unlawful
wielding of it which creates a false
gospel because you guys don't understand
the law gospel distinction and you
intermingle the two which results in a
false gospel
and he wants you to have that rest. I
want to read something to you I thought
that was very interesting in conclusion
here. Take my yoke upon me you will find
rest for your souls. Sabbath is all
about enjoying that rest.
Have you ever heard the poem of the
crooked calf path?
One day through a primal wood a calf
walked home as good calves should but
made a trail all bent a skew a crooked
trail as all calves do. Since then 300
years have fled and I assume the calf is
dead but still he left behind his trail
and here in lies my zany tale. The trail
was taken the very next day by a lone
dog that passed that way. And then a
wise bellweather sheep pursued the trail
over veil and steep and drew the flock
behind him too, as good bell weathers
always do. And from that day or hill and
glade through those old woods a path was
made. And many men wound in and out and
dodged and turned and bent about and
uttered words of righteous wrath because
it was such a crooked path. But still
they follow, do not laugh, the first
migrations of the calf. And through this
winding wood they stalked because he
wobbled when he walked.
The forest path became a lane that bent
and turned and turned again. This
crooked lane became a road where many a
poor horse with his load toiled on
beneath the burning sun and traveled
three miles in one. And thus a century
and a half they trod the footsteps of
that calf. The years passed on in
swiftness swiftness fleet. The road then
became a village street and this before
men were aware it became a city's
crowded thoroughfare.
And soon the central street was this of
renowned metropolis. And men two
centuries and a half trod in the
footsteps of the calf. Each day a
100,000 route followed that zigzag calf
about or this crooked journey went the
traffic of a continent. A 100,000 men
were led by one calf near three
centuries dead. They followed still his
crooked way and lose 100 years a day.
For thus such reverence is lent to
wellestablished precedent. A moral
lesson here this might teach where I
ordained or called to preach. For men
are prone to go it blind along the calf
paths of the mind and work away from sun
to sun to do what other men have done.
They follow on the beaten track and out
and in and forth and back and still
their devious course pursue to keep the
path that others do.
They keep the path a sacred groove along
which all their lives they move and how
the wise old wood gods laugh. Who saw
the first primeval calf?
You get that?
It starts with a a calf meandering
through the woods and then followed by a
dog and then the sheep and then a man
cuz it's a little easier going down a
beaten trail and pretty soon everybody's
winding along and they're paving this
weaving road
and maybe that's what's happened to the
church is people are following a
tradition of men and not the
commandments of God. What does the Lord
want us to do? Oh, but Lord, I might be
different. Jesus said, "You follow me,
you're going to be different." But how
could all the churches be wrong? Well,
that's what they said about the
religious leaders in Christ time. If
he's the Messiah, why doesn't everyone
else believe in him? If you're going to
be a Bible Christian, you need to follow
the Bible. Follow the word of God. So,
is Sunday sacred? Now, it's just another
working day. There's only one day in the
Bible God is blessed. That's the seventh
day Sabbath. Amen. You want to be a a
doer of the word and not just a hearer,
friends. Amen.
Right, Doug. And when God blessed that
day, it was man's first day, as we
looked at in part one. It was not man's
seventh day. It was God's.
And man began his week in holy communion
with God. But then sin broke that
fellowship fellowship,
which is in part why Jesus came to
redeem what man broke and restore it.
But after all of that,
all Doug has is a silly poem that has
absolutely nothing to do with Christians
meandering a path that some aimless
individual started and then everyone
followed with no precedent.
That isn't an argument, Doug. It's just
classic SDA piley or or piety veiled in
a cute delivery which misrepresents
those you're seeking to apply it to. and
then adding in the soft emotional music.
You didn't refute anything in your
presentation. You engaged in a bunch of
hopscotch exesus. You bounced all over
the Bible, making a bunch of assertions,
misrepresentations, and bearing false
witness. You didn't mention new creation
a single time, whether in detail or even
in passing. It's the central hinge of
the discussion. And you're not even
aware of that basic fact. You didn't
steal man the position that you were
then going to critique because you don't
even know it.
This was a a standard prepackaged
Sabbath talk from the SDA message mill
that as a former Adventist we've heard
parited 500 times. All the same sources,
all the same quotes, all the same proof
texts.
He said that's what happened to the
church. People are following the
commandments of men instead of the
commandments of God. That's rich.
Considering Seventh Day Adventism is a
tradition with your own novel concepts
and doctrines and culture and your own
arbitrary standards of what it even
means to keep the Sabbath, your own
novel God concept of the heavenly trio,
whether clean meats are or aren't
allowed, whether tea and coffee are
actually sinful, whether dress reform is
still needed and uphel still needs to be
upheld or not, and on and on and on.
You guys live in one big tradition that
developed in the northeastern peninsula
of the United States in the 19th century
because the fact is everyone has
tradition
and tradition isn't a bad thing.
How one utilizes that history is what
matters. Just because it's not inspired
doesn't mean it's useless.
But it's, as we saw, it's obvious why
you guys want to dismiss it, though. Cuz
it's not on your side whatsoever. You
have to utilize conspiracy and hasty
generalization to try and bolster why
all of history is foreign to your
claims. But more importantly,
not a single thing that Doug presented
refutes why the Christian church
worships corporately on the first day.
None of it.
Just citing a verse, Adventists, just
citing a verse and assuming your
position and understanding of the text
is not an argument.
Doug didn't exeute a single thing in
this whole yet yet SDAs will point to
something like that and go see he really
knows his Bible. Look how much Bible
he's citing.
No, you just assume your understanding
of the text and make a bunch of
assertions. That's called begging the
question.
They think their position is obvious,
which is why Doug said stuff like
they're hiding their eyes. Uh no, the
irony. That's the exact problem you all
have. You're not seeing the bigger
picture.
You're locked in to your your preset
great controversy programming and
worldview such that you can't see
anything outside of it. And then you
wonder why everyone else is not seeing
at all what you guys are claiming.
They don't all necessarily have the same
reasons for why they arrive why we all
arrive at the same conclusion, but we
all disagree with you. Just use AAM's
razor. It's not this grand conspiracy to
where you have to completely rewrite all
of history and come up with these
elaborate No, it's just the obvious
answer. You guys are wrong. Everyone
else was not wrong until you guys came
along to correct everyone. I know it
feels good to feel part of a club, like
you have a special insight into things
that no one else has.
Nostnosticism is not new.
But then it's because of the great
controversy that you wonder why everyone
else isn't seeing the same thing that
you've contrived up with your wild
theories and conspiracies and all sorts
of other missing links.
That's the problem. Not Christians
hating God's law. Not Christians hiding
their eyes. Not the Pope. Not Roman
Catholics. Not Constantine. Not
tradition. Not the church fathers. Not
the council of Leodysia. Not former
Adventists.
It is your extra biblical great
controversy worldview that we supposedly
have to have according to Herb Douglas
to even be able to understand the Bible.
Recall the series of claims from the
whole talk, y'all. If you saw both
parts, he started the first five minutes
talking about the history of what being
a a Trojan horse means, which set the
stage to claim the first day Sabbath is
a Trojan horse that brought with it all
sorts of other deceptive doctrines. He
then quoted Genesis 2. Didn't catch it
that it wasn't man's seventh day, it was
God's. It was man's first day based on
evening to evening. Then third, he
claimed the Lord's day had to be
Saturday because John was working in the
coal mines in on Patmos but but refused
to to work on the 7th day Sabbath, which
is when the revelation vision was given
to him. This after he utilized the
verbatim fallacy for Christians, saying
we have to have a single verse that
verbatim says Sunday is the new Sabbath.
Then he talked about the calendar
changing, but that it didn't actually
change the weekly cycle. Again,
irrelevant to the Christian Sabbath
position. That isn't the claim here.
Then he talked about a story of a guard
standing post who had no clue why he was
doing what he was doing to try and say
that's a picture of Christians bearing
false witness.
By that same standard, I can point to
individual Adventists that don't know
why they do what they do. Yet, people
like Doug would say, "Well, the answers
are out there. They may just not have
been taught well." which is precisely
the point. So stop lying about
Christians. Then he used hasty
generalization fallacy to say he went
and talked with a couple local pastors
down the street and because they didn't
have a strong theology around the
subject. That means Christians as a
whole have no basis for why they do what
they do. Didn't even bother to consult
theologians. I I mean shoot cited he
cited John Gil and Spurgeon
for Colossians 2:16.
Read the same individuals dug on the
Sabbath.
Clearly, he didn't read John Gills uh
commentary specifically. I I I haven't
read Adam Clark's enough to know, but I
have read John Gills enough to know. He
clearly didn't read John Gills enough to
see that John Gil goes into new
creation.
But then Doug went through all the first
day passages and just made a bunch of
assertions that aren't even made by
Christian theologians who have pointed
to these passages and how they
supplementally support why the church uh
worships on the first day. They're
supplemental. They don't hinge on those
verses.
And again, he used the verbatim fallacy
multiple times, showing he doesn't even
understand the new creation whatsoever.
Then he burned the straw man of if God
was going to change one of his
commandments, he would have told us
completely missing that God himself does
change the form of the fourth
commandment between the first and second
giving of the law. Which shows us that
yes, the ceremonial form of the command
can and has changed while the substance
remains the same. which is exactly what
the Christian Sabbath position
recognizes and believes. Then he asked
if the apostles made this change or if
they even had the authority to do such
and said no, which is totally false
because we see they had this authority
in Acts 15 at the Jerusalem Council
regarding circumcision which utilizing
Doug and the SDA church's own standard
should have been eternal because it too
was said to be forever.
But nevertheless, he failed to even
recognize that the only dated documented
cases of Jesus corporately gathering
after the resurrection are on the first
day. He tried to say some of those were
Monday and Thursday, etc.
Jesus began this practice and teaching
with the apostles who then handed it
down to us today. He appealed to Jesus
keeping the Sabbath yet failed to
recognize that Jesus changed that habit
and that was in the old creation.
Then he claimed we've changed the
scriptures and cited Revelation 22 and
said it applies to us not to take away
or the plagues of God will be added to
you. Yet his own church's Bible
paraphrase has altered that specific
text by allowing for additions to be to
the revelation as long as they aren't
contradictory as we looked at Jack
Blinko's rendering. Then he launched
into a whole chain of standard fair
historical revisionism and conspiracy
theories that are easily falsifiable
especially in the age of the internet.
followed by citing a silly poem with
sappy music and loaded questions like,
"Don't you just want to believe the
Bible, friends?"
Just begging the question that his
position is correct and to disagree
means you don't believe the Bible
and all of that was supposed to be what
refutes the first day Sabbath.
Not even close.
You didn't use the historical
grammatical method of interpretation
that Ted Wilson claims is the only
approved interpretation method of your
church, Doug.
There was no walking through any of the
texts, examining the grammar and the
historical context. There was no
examining what the original audience
that the texts were written to would
have understood.
You're going to have to do a lot better
than that.
Whether you agree with my position or
not, hopefully this was beneficial to
you. I know lots of Christians do not
agree with me on this. That's fine. The
purpose of this presentation was not to
get into every aspect of whether or not
the Sabbath was present in Eden, if the
Ten Commandments transcend Sinai, etc.
It was to demonstrate that this movement
does not know what they criticize and
they leave people with phobia,
irrational fear. Christian, you do not
need to fear corporately gathering and
worshiping on Sunday.
These two streams were to show that the
subject is a lot more complex and wide
than the SDA church loves to paint to
make it appear like Christians are just
clueless and ignorant or they hate God.
They're in a dazed and confused lull and
they're just in need of a simple
biblical clear SDA truth that they have
to share. Again, painting a caricature
idea of what's actually going on.
So hopefully this was beneficial to you.
Thank you for being with me tonight. I
had a pretty bad headache all evening,
so sorry that was kind of bugging me at
some points, but thank you for being
here. I want to remind you, you guys can
also visit answeringadventism.com to
partner with us, learn more about what
we're doing and so much more. So, make
sure to check that out. It is our gift
to you. Believe the gospel, friends, the
pure, undiluted gospel. Only the person
and work of the true Christ can save.
You cannot you cannot add anything to
that. Obedience is a fruit of already
being reconciled, not something that
maintains one's peace with God. We are
going to be rolling out more
conversations with SDAs like we did on
Monday. And you're going to see a
recurring theme.
Well, my union with Christ is maintained
by things I'm doing. No, you you don't
get it. You don't get it.
Jesus and Jesus alone provides that. You
cannot add or take away from any of
that. The Judaizers in Galatia only
added one thing to the gospel, saying
one had to get circumcised in order to
truly come to Christ and have peace with
God. Paul says they were under a curse
from God
because they changed the gospel which
resulted in no gospel at all.
health message, spirit of prophecy in
Ellen White's writings, young earth
creationism, seventh day Sabbath,
investigative judgment, none of that is
the gospel message or what the apostles
preached as the good news. If you are
trusting in any of that to find peace
with your maker, you will not find it.
Trust in Christ alone. Friends, as
always, until next time, God bless.
[Music]